you get perfect
[Music]
what's up guys hi my name is dobiziola
Thomas whatever you want to call me this
is the dope as usual podcast I'm here
with my co-host Marty O'Neill what's up
guys
bring it back
God I missed that God I missed that
intro man
[Music]
what's up guys sup this show is about
life drugs problems accomplishments and
everything in between not being
tiptoeing around YouTube and doing it
ourselves that's what this show is about
that's what this is all about guys let's
get right back into this if you haven't
noticed we are back in our studio we're
back we're back [__] back
that's it if you haven't seen us in a
while good to see you it's been a minute
so I'm talking to this camera for just
just a second
you guys know last August let's just
break it down now that we're back let's
talk about it because you're gonna ask
so let's just talk about it
um last August me and Marty were like yo
we're gonna sign this deal you guys
heard about like the studio we're moving
with Tyson all these people great that's
dope
here's what happened
malka the people we worked with they do
their thing they run some of the biggest
shows on Earth
don't do your thing that's sick we just
work at different paces
and we want different things I think at
the end of the day and I explained it to
Marty it's like um we had like a 15
person team over there but
when I this is the example say I own a
restaurant and I hire somebody to run
the restaurant they clock out at five
why do they care about what happens at
eight why do they care about what
happens before the shift do they truly
care probably not it whether or not the
restaurant does good or not they're
getting paid
and I'm not saying people weren't trying
but when we were at the studio Marty and
I noticed like yo there's 15 people
they're doing their jobs they're doing
their things they're doing it
we would have done that in three days
and not saying they're bad but Marty and
I this is our baby this is our
restaurant there's no time to stop like
well it's
six it looks like I'm done for the day
like nah bro what
so that's that's not bad on their part
that's just a company like why would you
expect them to be like oh it's three in
the morning let's get this done like no
no why would you do that it's not your
job I'm not gonna work off to off my
hours so I understand
so that's how I feel like Marty and I
can I'll stay up all night and get that
done Marty crushed it
and I'm just gonna say what I feel I
feel like
I was tiptoeing a little bit
[__]
so yeah I just said good all right so I
feel like I was tiptoeing a little bit
this is not monetized
um also we got demonetized from YouTube
and age restricted no notifications
after we signed with the big people so
we're like yo our reviews are going low
we're not getting paid on that no more
this doesn't seem like a very good move
but it wasn't that it was the the fans
the fans were like bro this has a
different feel not bad
but something's different and I agree
yeah totally how did you feel
I felt just like see yeah yeah yeah it
was really a long slow ramp up even to
to anything with them so it was just
like a lot of anticipation and I felt
like
things were just going to go a lot
faster than they did and then
recommendations were higher yeah we had
super high expectations it's not like it
was no dog [__] no no it's just like it
was kind of like letting somebody else
watch your kid yeah and you get back
like yo yo so why do you put the clothes
there now well they said they put that
knots down there I put the clothes full
you know that that's kind of how I feel
but you know I think is the big takeaway
is like you just can never really
when you have something that you built
up that's real special like or just a
tip Marty
just like that not the whole you see him
in the side just the tip and then do
this oh yeah yeah
it's been a minute it's been a minute
since I smoked a joint
that's the last episode oh because last
time we filmed was a month ago we took a
month we have a month off because we
filmed so many episodes and then we were
posting them that's not what we do but
it was like we kind of let our team stop
we stopped building our team once we
realized we were going to silent in with
them and kind of let our foot off the
gas and that's one thing that we'll
never do again in terms of overall
output because when you record a podcast
when you have a podcast it's way more
than just doing the episodes there's
everyday work that it takes to continue
to grow and to push the show and a lot
of different we got that straight
there's a lot of things that go out day
to day out
and like I just I felt like At first is
what we it was always our goal at first
to just get to the point that I was like
damn we weren't a [__] big label
coming in and taking this boom to that
kind of like in rap like in that record
deal but what we learned was just no
this is this is us this is what we do
we're here this is our show we have to
be Hands-On yeah we have to so that's
just not the goal the goal isn't to go
get some deal it's to grow it from
within but we thought the hold on life
problems drugs accomplishments and
everything in between problem and it's
an in-between we thought
we were gonna like you know we signed
this deal Stratosphere and then we
realized like bro we were in our
Stratosphere we were going up
by ourselves I I think it like boot one
thing I'll take away is it boosted the
[__] out of my confidence knowing like
oh I can outwork a team
sick and I'm not like again I'm not
saying you guys don't work I'm saying
24 hours a day so like if things take a
week I could have got it done in a day
yeah well there was just I mean if you
guys follow us on social media there's
just been months where we've had very
low like output overall no clips going
out no really being able to post on the
episode days because we're also you know
between us on top of this we're still
running these other channels too the
dobizola adventures the developers up
until this point so we've been just
still cranking out
but it's a great lesson to be learned
you know there's it's I've always like
and it's not like we sold away the
rights of the show or some [__] it was a
collaborative thing yeah so it's like we
were still technically independent but
we just needed to tighten up and just
get back to the Vibes that we always had
and felt like we were missing yeah
that's really it and we got headphones
back on I can hear myself I can hear the
soundboard I'm ready like this is the
feeling
and it just it started to feel a little
bit too uh like
just kind of like those press run
episodes of just getting people before
they have something to drop and they're
just kind of in and out and quick not so
personal that's not really I will say
that
atmosphere my favorite episode we ever
did my favorite artist
we had some of my favorite episodes I
will trade that episode
forever yeah to come back here um
well we got to do it we got the DJ Drama
we got the professor we got the Matt
Barnes we had a lot of great episodes I
think some of our best interviews like
oh that we could interview the [__] out
of people yes also that's not what we
need to do every episode no not every
episode needs to be this is what I found
out I was missing that's why this
camera's here today
when we first started the show me and
Marty would look at the camera and talk
did we ever once look at the camera at
the at this new studio no nope
no no I was really very impersonal yeah
focus on just the interview impersonal
we'll never do that to you guys again
that's it
now we know Wayne's basement is Wayne's
basement for a reason yeah we don't need
to sign with Rob Lowe we don't need that
deal we don't need that five thousand
dollar check yeah so what we did do was
kind of turn to our own people here
within the community give everybody
first dibs uh starting to help us build
back our own team it's just me and you
guys it's just Marty and I you see no
jumpers they got like 30 employees it's
just Marty and I I mean that's what we
want to get we want walk in and go damn
it's life just popping you're making
Clips hell yeah we don't have that now
we're like that's what we need that's
actually the goal that's the goal yeah
so Marty and I after this have five
interviews he did five interviews we
have five people to pick from Clips uh
dope is Yola's [__]
podcast edits P we need somebody to sit
right behind these cameras while we're
filming we're building out the team all
right we're building out the team
we need the team we have to it can't be
me and you anymore it can't it can't it
can
if we want to stay where we're at
Forever which is good
but if you're like hitting like two base
or hits somebody like I can crack at
home well the minute you stop in
anything in life the minute you stop
evolving you're going against the grain
of what life's all about
so it's like for us it was a tricky
situation like damn we're not going to
keep having our own employees when we're
about to sign with this label and keep
building up our team so I was like
kind of like the slow thing where it's
like damn then after a couple months go
by it's like man we're not we're not
playing offense at all all we're doing
is cranking out episodes that's not our
style that's not how we've we've always
I'm going to be completely honest I told
you before
I thought the show was gonna die
I'm gonna be honest I I was imagining it
like
damn we had a real good run man that's
what I was thinking like
we lost that spark something's gone even
me watching in the chat like
typing like I'm not laughing out loud
I'm not cackling yeah and I'm I'm
[__] tearing during the episodes when
I'm at home doing the chat
I didn't find myself like cracking up I
found it more of a chore to get through
my episode our episode like that and
that's not a good sign yeah so moral of
the story We shot for the stars and
realized bro we're past the Stars
already like what's next
that's how I feel totally I mean it's a
big life lesson across the board and
we're not trying to say we're the
coolest people ever and the biggest
numbers
I'm just saying like when we meet fans
and like the podcast that [__] helped me
like I don't uh that's what matters
and I don't think that would have became
coming from the episodes that we're
putting out yeah no it's our little
world in here like we talked about it
like when the fans or when the guests
come in here they enter into our little
world like to see the art this is all Us
in here this is but over there it's like
Tyson yeah other guys Tony Hawk Kevin
Garnett it's like that's cool
but books are poster at yeah it was
there it's we were out of our I made our
own poster yeah okay no it just felt
like I was living with a roommate of a
family that was already tight and we
were moving in as a new people which is
cool and takes time but
we put way too much work and timing to
be like is it cool if I go over here
like
uh [__] that go yell [__] and
obscenities in the warehouse if you want
piece of [__] go smoke a pound
all we ask is knock on the door make
sure everyone's in the bathroom
the Only Rule like in the in Ninja
Turtles what you want Menthol or regular
when he goes into this Foot Clan
soldiers thank you Marty yeah when he
goes to the Foot Clan soldiers Hideout
that's how I feel here and over there
it's kind of like the first day of
Kindergarten Cop when he's walking well
this is going to be your classroom
okay [__] that's how I felt like more I
got to put on a little front yeah I'm a
cop underneath this kindergarten yeah
and I was like I'm an obscene [__]
underneath this post that's how I felt
over there like totally
[__] I wanted to scream [__] so hard
and I I mean last last thing
the first time I heard my my word [__]
bleeped
it crushed my heart
let's talk I mean I think people like
our show just because it's raw and it's
like
we're saying what we want to that's what
we're just trying to buy by YouTube
though yeah it's really YouTubers and
yeah we don't want to sit around and
[__] whine about YouTube forever but
it's like but this is what we're doing
now we're now fully accepting cannabis
sponsorships we're already talking to
six companies we're going full what we
want to do we're not tiptoeing around
YouTube we're not monetized we're not
getting notifications going out we're
Shadow band
oh you can eat a dick we're we're gonna
get paid we're gonna get and it's not
even the YouTube money it was being on
YouTube's good side yeah like yeah
YouTube
uh-huh that's all it was for now we're
like damn you guys are pissed at us
because it's just it doesn't feel good
when it's like even when you're trying
to appease this like invisible [__]
rule book that you're trying to like
appease through the episodes and then
that's not working it's like what are we
trying to appease these fools for you
also one other thing last thing about
this little move I'll talk about
Marty and I we did it we did what nle
Choppa Rob 49 Big Jay oakerson Dizzy
Wright were all booked in the same day
with half an hour in between shows
like a like a like a like an assembly
line hey where are you born okay get out
of here hey what's your next album Juan
get out of here anything you would like
to promote get out of here I don't like
that [__]
I want the guest to be like today is
your day we're here for you DJ ghost
episode you that type of shirt yeah
you're ready we're here yeah there's no
what's your heart out I have a watch
yeah and I [__] did the no wrist
watch look right now
I was like what time is it [__]
but I don't like that feeling I like
who cares it's over
we're back it'll never happen again
thank you guys for sticking around
soundboard's back I missed this [__] you
I don't like not having that I know I
didn't have anything to do with my hands
yeah I'll dig a Knights
why are you just in episodes like this
um
okay anything else you want to touch on
on on that aspect I just feel like
myself again it fell outside of myself
to not have the show be my whole
lifestyle
it's a full lifestyle it's not a job so
I felt like when's the next episode
coming up when's the next oh yeah that's
right it's out of our nature to not be
pushing forward so that feels weird it
does because every day every week up
until like that whole zippering in was
constant progress that's always what it
is like updates like we're always
putting bricks up on the wall and then
you stop putting bricks up on the wall
and you stop building your wall for a
little bit until you mean it's like
can't wait around for somebody to build
your [__] wall that's all and it
would have worked with them over time
but we don't got the time
we we want to do it now yeah like why
would I what am I going to do when I
told you I have two days off what the
[__] remember I told you that I'm like I
don't know
I don't know what to do my free time
you know I did I drove in my car for two
hours and smoked weed
I don't have hobbies because I am
why the [__] do I need a hobby there's
[__] to get done
super true I had two days off two weeks
in a row and I was going [__] insane
yeah
I don't like that [__] I don't like
sitting there going I don't got nothing
to do let's spark a joint do something
like for
It's gotta be it's gotta be something I
can get done and it almost made me feel
lazy and then I got comfortable with
feeling like that yeah and then it got
to we filmed three episodes in a week we
didn't film again for two weeks it was
only filmed once a week I have five days
off one week
yeah and I went nowhere I remember
they're like yeah let's go on vacation I
was like vacation vacation for where I'm
the opposite go on a vacation I feel
like what yeah like no thank you
so we're back and all they got isn't
that sound crazy it's like
I I need to work I need to get something
done like that's how I feel like a
junkie or something I mean that's what
it takes to grow your own business
though yeah if or I can sit around 10
years going damn I should have just went
harder yeah no no see enough movies to
go damn this [__] [__] up back then
that's the the point of us not leaving
there is the point of when the movie
stopped the main character starts
narrating and this is the point where I
realized everything was done yeah I mean
it's like I mean picture like
I moved my whole family out to
California we got our whole lives going
and then after a couple years we moved
to Texas
but to decide while we're in Texas that
all right this isn't working out
gonna have to move back
like it's that same type of like sick
feeling of like oh my God but i j i
can't let this string on any longer just
for the sake of not accepting that it's
not working out and biting the bullet
and doing what it takes to just go back
home
so go back home is our homes full of
weed and fun so like yeah go ahead let's
go back home
so once again we're not saying anything
bad we're just saying we work at
different paces
we are different style of podcasting
that's it that's really what it is we we
sign with the deal as tech nine but
we're really underground [__] has done
Strange Music in our own [__] exactly
that's a great comparison we'll get off
that topic guys let's just say we're
back we're never [__] leaving
I swear to God there was one night I
almost singled teared and I was in my
bed thinking about what the show's done
lost something
um
yeah but I mean you look at you look at
any show that's been around for a long
time and it's just like we haven't been
around for a long time it's been only
two years solid but I'm saying like when
you look at the course when for shows
that have been around for a long time
you can look back and see different
chapters how the floors
over time that's just you know it's kind
of natural and just remember this guys
we have a really good guess
we got some good guests out of this
steel like we got we got you know I got
my favorite [__] rapper in my life
was so fun and nice crazy
I got my Crenshaw album signed
talking to the professor professor
like above and beyond nice as [__] off
camera we're like a rat's a he didn't
even say ass he's very Christian I don't
drink
[__] Kobe you right after like
like we got to talk to our childhood
Legends so I will say that I will shout
out to the agency for getting that [__]
done
because that was very cool and we I
guess we could say it now but
the reason I went to New York was
because we were supposed to do all the
Impractical Jokers
but we we kind of left the agency and
we're like hey you know we're not with
you can you still get that done I didn't
want to ask that but yeah all the
Impractical Jokers are like yup we'll do
your show
one of my favorite shows of all time so
I just want to break the ice and break
it to you like it didn't happen
because uh yeah we're going back on the
offense with all this type of shot don't
even stress I'm I'm
get ready guys and also before we get
into this next thing do you want to hit
this bomb yeah of course yes because we
don't give a [__] anymore and we're
gonna get high and pretend that
pretend that YouTube was just Lexus
like they love this they love this yeah
YouTube loves bongers don't they
I mean Joey Diaz and Rogue any rip bongs
don't be biased
hey what's up guys just taking a moment
to talk about one of our long time
sponsors and this is manscaped
introducing manscape's Father Day
package for your dad's package meaning
dick and balls and also if it's not your
father it could be a father figure for
your father's figure help him shave
those pubes worldwide across the entire
Globe manscaped has 8 million customers
okay that's 16 million balls of proof so
right now get your Father's Day present
go right now to manscape.com that is our
discount code that's 20 off plus free
shipping for your dad's balls weed
whacker 2.0 the trimmer the lawnmower
4.0 ball deodorant ball toner pair of
boxer briefs and a travel bag to make
sure you take everything with you it's
on the go it's perfect it's the grooming
kit for every man in the world and for
all the Lumberjack men out there that
have beards the beard hedger Pro kit is
for you the kit comes with a beard
hedger beard shampoo beer conditioner
beard oil beard balm and it comes with
two free gifts the scissors and combs so
right now go to demandscape.com forward
slash Yola or use our discount code at
checkout 20 off plus free shipping thank
you guys for supporting the brands and
support us back to this super long
episode
make a red Z
okay hold on say it again make it red
that's what this weed is Mega red Mega
red okay yeah
um that [__] that you had earlier was
Preposterous from cbx yeah cbx cereal
milk
possibly the most intense nuggets I've
ever seen in my life it literally stuck
to the wall you watched it happen
okay so let's get on to this next thing
Marty while you rip this actually you
know what let's take a second
let's rip a ball on our show that we
never do let's go let's do this real
quick
go first
if you want there you go
so while Marty's doing that we'll get
ready I'm fully just sorry right now so
I'm fully converted to hemp look these
days too I know I don't have any here we
don't have any in the building but I
took it all home I made it because we
don't come here anymore because we left
the show
I did that to us all right Marty's lungs
are getting rough because of meat I'm
very sorry
[Music]
why do you have lungs of a champion
toss that over here
no really oh my God
was just durable it is it is
it could have just been
flooded of water real quick I've seen
that happen it's very sad
um I still have my one piece that is a
testament to these pieces boy yeah I
still got the same one
we're looking to come with some new
colors too with these things yeah they
can't make orange glass but I'm we're
trying to figure out a way to make a
nice orange one yeah we got you guys so
Marty we're back that story is
officially done we're here
I'm gonna hit this bong and I'm gonna
I'm gonna get real intimate with this
camera real quick start oh [__] start
talking straight to the camera because
I'm gonna tell you guys what went down
fully
you know what I won't say where it was
but I would talk about talk about the
the car situation fully okay so I talked
about live on Tick Tock a little bit
here I like not being able to see the
nose this is like mysterious you guys
have no idea what really happened
I've never felt discriminated against
before
that can't be true no like to my face
I've never felt like whoa
is it this on some like racially
motivated I don't know what it was
I don't think it was racial
I don't know what it was or just that
they youtubed you type [__]
I'll tell you right now
hi let's go guys
Benny like that cocaine pose yesterday I
noticed
yeah we're steps away from Betty the
butcher being over here
you keep saying yeah when I'm in town
like all right hit us up they're in like
Greece and Poland and [__] Bro there's
some of the hardest rappers on the
planet if they don't come through it's
okay I'm still gonna listen
I love those fools oh you know the
joints
all right here we go here we go here we
go here we go damn use power smoked that
[__] yeah man I already knew I just like
looked at mine too Jesus oh [__] don't
keep smoking we'll raw weed YouTube
loves We Roll downtime
are you ready Marty oh yeah
[Music]
story time
it's time for Story Time full in-depth
detail just leaving out the location
in depth
here we go
you guys know I love uh uh Mercedes cars
I've always wanted one so I got one two
years ago it was super fun dream car
then I thought you know what maybe I can
try to get a Maybach because you know
it's a pretty insane car like that'd be
pretty awesome right
so
um I ordered one so I ordered one not
like you know I don't get it it took a
long time and then I was like you know
what I'm gonna order one
you guys know that I've been waiting I'm
not gonna bore you you know tune or
December's supposed to drop
January February March
anyway who cares why am I complaining
I'm gonna tell you what happened car
lands at a Mercedes locations here in
California won't say which one
car lands
I send them the wire
doesn't go through I'm like okay cool
weird My Luck
send them a second wire failed
third wire the third day
doesn't go through again
they're looking at me like is there
money in your account
like bro
yeah I want to buy this car
and then you know what happened
Third Day the guy goes oh sorry I
realized I gave you the wrong Bank
information
three times
he gave me the wrong Bank information he
does this every day it's not like it's
for like a regular little bicycle
for
I'm not going to be trying to be a dick
it's a pretty expensive [__] car
you're [__] up how are you doing this
you know what all right it's fine you
know what and I'm always like don't you
know what it happens man don't even you
know me I don't want to hurt no one's
feelings plus I want you to give me that
car I'm not trying to like be rude I'm
not going to be rude anyway I'm never
gonna be rude to somebody unless they're
[__] rude to me or I feel like did
you just blow me off [__] you [__]
that's when I started like my waitress
the other day stupid [__]
anyway
um
he finally gives you the right
information I send the information I
send the wire you ready to go oh by the
way already approved me
and sent me a proof of purchase
confirmation congratulations on the
first Maybach 2023 I'm like oh my God
like
real
then it goes to send the fourth wire
send it and they go what's dope as Yola
mean and I go that's my DBA Thomas rajo
DBA dobiziola doing business as
I'm the house I'm standing in I got with
that name sir because it's legal like I
make videos I didn't say that like yeah
just you know a name I use and I I mean
it's my DBA he goes well yeah we can't
accept that dope as yellow is not buying
a car it's Thomas Rojo I'm like okay
all right but do you like want my DBA
information because if my bank account
says both names have you done this
before that's what I was thinking like
have you do you know what do you know
what you're doing
like I'll help you like I'll help you
you accept my money and give me my
[__] car that's what I was thinking
like what is the problem
fourth wire right and they go if you can
send us like the information do you have
the DBA ago yes sir I have the DPA
can you send it 100 I can send it to you
over the Internet over the interwebs I
will send this to you in seconds Sir
send it to them oh yeah no that's not
gonna work it still says Thomas raw Hugo
did you think it wasn't
did you think my real name's dope is
Yola because if that's the case you
wouldn't have approved me sir two weeks
ago you wouldn't approve my information
this is all ongoing I'm like you know
what I'm in my room pacing like you know
what it happens don't worry I'll send
another wire under my actual name even
though my CPA says do not buy this car
under Thomas or albino and they go well
I guess you can't do that now so you're
costing me taxes right off thank you
dick but I can transfer it later just a
hassle sorry if this is boring you ready
here's where it gets good
they look up dope as yellow and go so uh
so what do you do like what is this and
I go I make new I make videos they go so
what is the dopest shop is this like
drugs you do you sell drugs are you a
drug dealer
just like that
are are these drugs do you sell drugs
are you a drug dealer
and I said no that's legal hemp that's
why you can look it up online sir
that's that's why I gave you the website
can you prove that you actually work or
own some of this and they go if you want
to look at the website that guy's face
is me
but yes I can prove it to you
gotcha and this is me biting my [__]
tongue Marty the whole [__] time when
Rose is going are you
kidding me
so I'm on speakerphone like don't worry
no no no totally understand I will get
you a proof from my partners with our
bank information on it if you [__]
need it
and our in our and our trademark like
what else do you need give them all that
they go
okay yeah all right okay yeah we just
want to prove your income like okay
since you just ask prove your income
instead of ask are you a drug dealer are
these drugs
so you know me I'm containing myself
because as of right now that was the
rudest she could ever ask me why the
[__] did you ask me if I'm a drug dealer
over the phone you never met me that's
really what pissed me off are you a drug
dealer like I used to be [__]
was this how far after this like this is
the fourth wire sitting I'm saying the
car has been there for two weeks sitting
in the [__] dealership waiting for me
after the whole Port situation oh sorry
they shipped it to San Diego from
Germany you know the port
and they shipped it to Northern
California when I live in LA and then
they made me pay for it to come back
well if you want to pay the fee or you
can come up here and drive it back go
you want me to drive a car across
California with no ceramic coating no
thank you sir
verify your means of income after that
whole ordeal after they approve me and
my taxes and I sent to my taxes with my
CPA approve me everything you had the
certificate chat then they started
questioning where my money is coming
from also guys I got this car at sticker
so like people don't make they make
nothing they were trying to wait me out
so they'd be like you know what [__]
keep your car and then go cool I can
make 90k today because that's how much
they were going over it's like bro I got
lucky but they were trying to play me
and see if I would be like well [__] you
but I don't know I stayed polite this
guy no no worries no
okay totally get it no worries DBA
doesn't work I'll send it in my name
don't worry give me two minutes and hang
up [__] screaming my ass so
pissed anyway
um
you know that happened they made me pay
for sixteen hundred dollars they made me
pay to get my [__] carbon isn't that
[__] up that's a lot
to put on a truck that was already
coming to L.A
[__] you yeah [__] you eat it like oh
but I was like no I'm not letting this
go this is my car I'm waiting six months
this is money [__]
back to the story
um send the fifth wire Rosie and I you
know we have different last names as
we're not married yet we will be since
we're not Maria her name's not chain her
name's not you know my last name which
makes no difference
you ready for what happened I send the
fifth wire under my bank account my
personal Toms Raul and Rosie you know
joint account normal
I send them the wire and they go oh so
we have a problem here this is the next
day I'm waiting day after day after day
after day
four days of this the trucker has showed
up four days in a row to get my car and
they're like well the wire didn't go
through so you have to leave the guy
spent the night in the hotel
one night the first night he's like oh
they'll get it done by the morning
four days and the weekend six days later
the guy came back
he came back four days in a row to get
the car and was like every day like the
wire still hasn't gone through
and I'm there just I have no oh sorry I
sold my car
because they said the car landed I had
no car I had been ubering for a month
what car
so that's really another bomber like bro
I'm ubering everywhere I moved out of La
I moved I moved like to Calabasas area I
don't live close anymore Uber to the
warehouse and [__]
anyway sorry I was complaining here and
[__] my bad my bad anyway fifth wire
sorry we have a problem I go what
yeah who's Rosie
my wife
well Rosie's not the one buying the car
it needs to be your name on the account
I go sir look right underneath her name
there's my name he goes oh yeah your
name is on year ago
yeah it is on there man yeah it's on
there for sure well you know her name's
first
okay
does that make sense to you her name's
first
it's not Rosie buying the cards Thomas
rajo your name needs to be first on the
account and I got upset and said is that
really what you want like is that
something that you've never encountered
a joint bank account
then they can unfold the manager
condescending as full
I let him have it very politely
so you asked me if I was a drug dealer I
everything I told you I said in politely
so you asked me I was a drug dealer you
sent four wires I've sent four wires
three of which your associate gave me
the wrong information I have waited here
the Char now you're making me pay 1600
to get it back
I understand your concerns
that's what he said to me like no I'm
not gonna fix anything I understand your
concerns he said you need to go into the
bank and get a certified letter from the
manager of the bank saying that your
name is on the account and I said sir
you can see my name on the account
because yeah but her name's first unless
you want to redo the paperwork and get a
notary I had to wait for a notary for a
week to come through and give my
paperwork too by the way
in between all this
if you want to wait again we can get her
to buy the car and buy the car under her
name
I'm like
I'll go to the bank dude get up you know
I'm sitting there like and John I let
John know and John lets people have it I
didn't want John to get on the phone
because I'm like dude I want the car I
don't want you to burn them yeah he's
justifiably upset but I let him know on
the way to a meeting I'm on the way to a
meeting while this is on the phone with
a guy like and then he John's like [__]
is going on I'm like
yeah I'll send my wife into the bank as
Rosie's in line waited an hour to talk
to the manager they call me back so we
called your bank yeah it's fine
hold on does John know these people
these are kind of randoms John has a car
connect this I'll get to this too John
is a car connect nice dude
he has the allocation so he can get
Maybach so you can get uh portion of
given five allocations go build your
Porsche only five people in the world
can do it I'm the guy that hands them
out gotcha right so that's John's got
he's a very like you know connected car
guy so
I'm calling I'm talking to him I'm like
yo what's up with your people over here
at Mercedes and he's you know
middlemanning this situation which I
appreciated
don't worry it's fine and I go cool can
you guys pick up the car today it's a
Friday and he goes actually the truck
driver is about 20 minutes away I can
drive it 20 minutes the guts of the car
dealer told me I can drive it to him
yeah if you authorize me to drive it
I'll drive him to the to the freeway and
I'll meet him on the freeway and I went
do not touch the car I'll just wait and
he goes well he can't be here till
Wednesday
I don't have a car again for five more
days and I went okay cool Wednesday
shows up oh man we we we're running late
actually it's gonna be tomorrow
delayed me again and I'm like every day
I'm sitting here just
trying not to let him have it so what
happened right there as I was waiting at
five days I posted this nice version of
me talking about this on Tick Tock you
might have seen it
I posted
so they asked me if I was a drug dealer
and you know I politely said no and I
got this house as dope as YOLO which
makes me feel a little weird that they
wouldn't take that the house doesn't
cost more than the car
they approved me I gave them the whole
Spiel I just gave you but within Tick
Tock terms a minute so this is what
happened I was really polite and I go so
I guess I'll wait again and I want the
car so have a good day and that's how I
ended the video like polite I didn't say
a cuss word nothing
people it went viral I deleted it since
then people went and I'll tell you why
people went nuts and tagged Mercedes
like 1200 times
on tick tock right going nuts I didn't
ask for that they're like damn
discriminating against my friend Thomas
that's crazy like look at this legal ass
video maker can't even get a car because
he considered a drug or you know people
are going nuts like damn Mercedes
falling off you know just going harder
Mercedes I never asked for it Mercedes
[__] DMS me
follows my accounts DMS Mingos
please let us know what happened and I
gave him the whole breakdown in the DM
of what happened I told him where where
I got the car I'm not going to tell you
guys
because I don't want it to go further
because it it gets worse
I give them names but yeah so and so the
manager real condescending real cool I
was being a dick my ear guys people suck
I was like why do I have to go through
this and I'm buying your the top card
the first one
and you're treating
me there should be a massaging your
shoulders and serving you champagne I'm
not trying to say in an a bougie way
dude I'm saying more like bro be nice to
me
that's all I ask
Ed
like if I was rude maybe they would have
been cool with me
like yo get my [__] done maybe they
might oh damn this guy needs business
sometimes that's how it goes I guess man
but I'm not gonna change who I am just
to get what I want never done that yet
so
um
I was polite anyway I said that on tick
tock
bro the car lands the next day I get the
car and I tell Mercedes I'm like I'll
let you know the VIN number and the
location tomorrow I just told them what
happened and the names because I didn't
want him to be like
yo what did you do to this guy and they
go [__] that [__] that in a car so I
wait until the car landed wherever the
car landed I pressed DMS in by the way
it was this place
I shot him
what else can I do I'm not gonna go on
Yelp
so
the next day John's car guy calls me 30
times in a row because I was filming and
I looked at my phone like what the [__]
happened
and he hits me up and the first thing he
says what the [__] did you post that's
all he said and I go what
and I'd never get upset with people I
never get rude
I'll let him [__] have it
it's like how could you post something
like that and I just lost my she's like
you can't be you need to take that and I
was like
and I I was out of my situation I just I
felt a little played and I was like
I don't usually talk like that but I was
like well you know shut the [__] up you
should be apologizing to me asking me my
[__] drug dealer
and I gave him the whole Spiel like you
should be [__] thanking me that I
didn't say it rudely I was so polite I
let Mercedes know I don't want to get
anybody in trouble I'm just letting you
know the situation I'm just telling you
please I don't want anyone fired or
anything crazy that's what I told him I
had the [__] DM
and I told him like bro if you if you
want me to be upset I can make another
[__] video real quick
and I usually don't get by I was so
[__] mad
he's asking you to just accept that and
shut the [__] up basically just because
like yes because yeah
and he told me he's like Mercedes
corporate went to the [__] dealership
and stripped them so they can't get
maybachs or allocations no more
because of what they how they treated me
Mercedes let me know like so this is
what we did
like oh no
because the guy called me like Mercedes
corporate is there what the [__] did you
post and then they called my car guy and
go don't ever [__] contact us again
they cut him off completely
and that's where I felt like a dick
that's why I started erasing it all I
was like gosh okay bro I didn't mean to
do that to you but also get your [__]
[__] together but I did feel bad after I
yelled at his stupid ass he told me he's
like bro they just [__] told me never
to call I'm like oh my God bro I'm so
[__] I genuinely felt bad and I told
him like I will post whatever you need I
will [__] apologize I'll make a post
saying I'm very sorry like if that's
gonna help you with them because [__]
that Mercedes dealership but also that's
his money I don't want him like losing
out now yeah because of me after he got
me the car this was like a eight month
or deal overall too it wasn't like a
small situation this [__] drug on like
when you're spending that much money
it's not supposed to be something you
have to [__] deal with for like weeks
bro I just felt so bad man
and he's like they just told me never to
[__] call again don't even show up
that's what they told the car guy like
don't even come by again
I feel bad he's like that's my best
friend's dad's spot
but I know that means I was a child like
and now he told me don't [__] come to
my shop ever again type [__] because
they're [__] up
because they were pieces of [__] and
we're [__] the thing is that they
weren't being super rude that's how I
felt bad so I told him I don't want
anybody in trouble or fire I'm just
letting you know like why the [__] am I
being asked from a drug dealer why am I
having to pay for a mistake of 1600
bucks I didn't do that you guys know I
live in Italy because I could have just
picked it up
you said you were bringing it to Newport
you said it's north California
anyway
um
that drug on
all that happened I know I'm sitting
here complaining about something I'm
very sorry but I needed to tell you guys
what happened after that Tick Tock video
because a lot of you guys saw and asked
why'd you take that Tick Tock down you
got scared huh a lot of people like damn
you scared of Mercedes
no scary Mercedes like I don't know I
just felt bad I felt genuinely [__]
bad yeah like damn I ruined your
relationship I'm so [__] sorry
I did not mean to do that [__]
but that's what happened shout out to
Mercedes was it worth it
the car overall I'll wait another six
months right now that car is [__]
incredible
what's your favorite thing about it I
don't know yet I haven't been in the
back seat and driven yet I've been
driving my car I don't have a I don't
like I don't really trust [__]
to drive my car
I need to get a driver but I don't have
anywhere to go
hey you want to sit at the warehouse for
four hours sit outside
yeah want to go to John's it's a block
uh-huh
that's a sick setup with the Sprinter
with uh how John's got it you know what
I mean with a block away yeah yeah but
it's like
I love driving the car I'll just say
that right now this car
I never thought I would be impressed
by a car
you were in it you were in the back seat
yeah it's amazing it goes full spa sauna
mode I found there's a nap mode for the
backseat where it blocks everything out
you put the heavens you lay down flat
I want to really sit back there and
chill one time like in the garage get
the lights going that's why I did the
other day I put on classic music with a
hell of violins and [__] and I HotBox a
car with Rosie and then we uh it was all
blue
oh damn it I've never felt more elegant
in my life I had the lap tray up I had
all the [__] gone and I was just in the
garage yeah
I've never been in the car outside of
the in the back outside of the car I
just sit in garages my garage and Hot
Box the car not for audio people it's
different oh yeah it's like it's so
weird all immersive and [__] it's almost
too much
it's crazy I will say that those Germans
I said this I think we cut it out of a
video but like I just wish like they put
this level of effort into something
positive like cars back then
because if they did that like 70 80
years ago we'd have a lot better
Earth I think right now and a lot less
violent
you know what I'm talking it's fair
thought you know what I'm talking about
put this kind of effort into like being
nice back then come on man fit into
kindness Jesus Christ the car is its own
person the car is amazing it's
incredible I can't I'm finding new [__]
all the time
anyway we'll get off that that's what
happened to the car that's the whole
situation I was polite the whole time
all right let's just say that was polite
as [__] even when I was yelling at this
man I was still polite I even said and I
know that's not your fault yeah very
sorry but this is how I feel I was even
being polite to him while I was talking
[__] that is the way to be there's
there's a way there's a place that I
think you do want to get to where even
in those circumstances you're not
actually acting angry when you are
never
some people do not they like I love it
some people won't act until you start
getting
hurt unfucking dude like that's terrible
so annoying I've learned that over the
past couple years like people don't care
unless you get pissed off and then
you're gonna look at me weird like why
the [__] do we have to get here to be
able to uh I'd rather just not be there
like I don't want to act like I don't I
don't act like this so why would I act
like this now it makes me feel gross it
makes me feel gross exactly dude
um
off the car topic okay oh next up I
wonder if they grow up fake Rick Ross
before he took their whole [__] brand
and uh in his criminal Enterprises and
[__] oh maybe actually yeah by the way
you guys realize like
you're every rapper's [__] brand and
you're gonna sit here and Grill me over
my [__] weed videos like relax me
back
I'll tell you off camera
but I found out who lived at my house
last
okay he's got their collections letter
oh [__]
perfect
I forgot to tell you that's a funny
thing to give
yo you never took a collections letter
in with you as proof of identity when
you're trying to get a loan though
[Laughter]
and I went
you put your name
as rapper name was on the collections
then I went
they're about to start calling you turn
around she
shut the [__] up I go
now we found because the neighbor's like
some rapper I was like oh he's like he
squatted here for like 12 months almost
15 months he's like they didn't pay rent
and they had a victim
and when I when I moved in there was
like weed packaging in weird places I
told you like underneath stuff like to
hold up [__]
like in the backyard like the canopy I'm
like take this canopy out he's broken I
don't want this [__] it's broken I told
my landlord like 12 times can you take
the canopy I don't want it when I move
in it's broken I'm still there when I
got there and I went to [__] throw I
was pissed and I moved him like there's
a bunch of weed packaging underneath
this thing likes flat
bro
a shocked I'm shocked how did they get
hold on where is it it's in the main no
but in one of the room is [__] hugees
how did they get
up and what rapper I'm talking about is
not tall so like you know I should shut
the [__] up and narrowing it down right
here we'll just stop at that
some guy
that I've heard that's funny I shot that
we've all heard before like super famous
that neighborhood is crazy
it's crazy uh I can't even say who lives
there because people don't know where I
live but on my block
six fools I've either listened to or
watch on TV constantly which is wild
never never once am I going to introduce
myself I don't want to know what I do
where I live nothing I walk in I drive
in my driveway and [__] close my [__]
you've never seen me ever again
sick
um damn
yo we're out of here ranting and [__] I
love this this is great
um
yeah I can't say that but my neighbors
you know my neighbors when I move I'll
be able to talk oh yeah then I told you
yesterday right
what I told you yesterday me and John
found out who lives right in between us
I didn't tell you yet
oh wait I said I would tell you okay so
John and I I like this rapper a lot John
likes this rapper John's wife likes his
rapper Rosie likes his rapper he's
[__] hard
and then he posted the picture I'm like
that's my backyard
well it's right above me
it's like a little slope in my backyard
and there's another set of houses
and he's between me and John so if
that's that house wasn't there that's
John's Street guys me and John live
right a one block away from each other
so
in between me and him is one of is like
a hard ass rapper I really like and I'm
like damn you just expose the whole
neighborhood in your pose bro damn you
got to live there to know where he lives
but that was his post in my backyard a
good thing there's nothing behind there
that says it's mine but yeah I was like
dude that is my yard are you kidding me
and then we scroll through and go [__]
that's whose car that I always wanted
like those cars are stupid tight
whose cars are those and now I know
whose car is they are it makes perfect
sense
um yeah it's really weird
give me give me a second I'm already
changing cameras you know why because
we're a team and this is the all the
people we employ that means Marty's Coho
slash camera operator okay we're working
on that we're building a team out
um why are you doing that
let's do this YouTube friendly bong rip
I've seen these bombs rappers post like
rapper will buy a new house and then
take a picture in front of the house oh
[__] what the [__]
I live in a gated community and I still
I know where a lot of people I like live
in my neighborhood because they Park
their [__] cars with their name on it
right outside like on the license plate
or on a rap or something
three okay so far guys listen by the way
the new house Vlog is coming soon oh
backyard is damn near complete I want to
show the front of the [__] house so
bad but I'm not gonna nope
all right real quick is this camera the
same direction
am I high I think it moved
it didn't move at all I'm burnt uh I
mean I took it off the tripod and oh the
tripod stayed though that's the whole
point of oh my sorry guys we're over
here just like not even in
to the topics right we're just like so
Marty's high and I'm high is that camera
crooked you know what this is what we're
here for man we need we needed this
episode so just to talk we haven't had a
solo in two months two months solid
Eight Episodes we're not supposed to let
that much life go by no no then you
forget what you did every day we're
doing something so I'm like oh I'll talk
about that on the show then I forget
so real quick as Marty's taking this
bong rip next segment I would like to do
all right oh
since we're back on the solo we haven't
had a solo if you guys watched the last
goblin episode that we did at the other
Studio
um Marty has a Rolex Goblin has Rolexes
I have my Space Jam watch my super duper
duper sick Space Jam watch I've had
since I was 10. I wore it as a joke
because I know you guys have sick
watches and during that episode if you
remember I busted out boom Space Jam
watch but I hate watches how they feel I
don't like it
I wore that watch the whole day you know
because the episode
loved it didn't bug me I'm like oh space
just Space Jams all look at Michael
Jordan like I was like oh this is sick
and when I tell you like
I think I kind of like watch this now so
I gotta watch right so that's why I have
a lot of you wondering if you haven't
seen the show and wondering why what
this [__] watch
yeah but watch now isn't that crazy
turns out I'm a wash guy turns out I
love them there's so much [__] that goes
into a man you've gotten me into him
I'll be on the Rolex website just
looking at all the learning about them
yeah it's really wild and a cool
investment honestly if they appreciate
if you get the right ones
um so real quick while we're doing that
I'm gonna pack this bowl I asked you
guys if you don't follow our Instagram
boom over the screen the dope as usual
podcast go follow that right there also
boom over the screen Marty made it
that's his Instagram and one more time
that's my Instagram I just got deleted
twice this month but I got it back here
we go that's my Instagram I posted on
there today follow all of our accounts
because we post a lot of [__] for the
show ready I asked fan questions if you
want to be featured on the show your
question let us know what you want to
know so Marty I'm going to run through
these fan questions I haven't told you
what I picked
let's do it guys we're back on Twitter
too by the way so all the social changes
thank you any type of stuff we can't
post on Instagram we're posting on
Twitter a lot of weed yeah we got a lot
of questions and paraphernalia on
Twitter so make sure you're following
that yes sir are you ready from
Instagram
charlie.305. shout out to you what's up
Thomas and Marty Charlie from from
Charlotte North Carolina here my
question for both of you is now that
you're a couple years into podcasting
game what are some things that you found
out that were different than what you
previously assumed originally assumed
that's what he said um
what are some things I mean I I know
right off the bat what I'm thinking yeah
I mean the biggest lesson overall is
this isn't you know like maybe it was
just the Mind stay like we talked about
earlier coming from being like a rapper
and [__] like always trying to go out
and get the big deal like that's not the
goal that's a real big takeaway that
it's okay to just accept that this is an
independent thing like
supposed to just be between you and the
fans and
Let it Grow from there organically and
show I think that'd be my biggest
takeaway
but also
just how cool it is to be able to sit
here and have these conversations and be
able to talk to people that like
I've looked up to Growing Up and [__] I
never really anticipated how just
[__] cool that was going to be
just life Milestones that's like damn
we're [__] lucky to be able to sit
here with like my Dorian shirt and have
these conversations
you know you gotta have that happen to
really register how [__] cool that is
have my kids want to go up to the studio
and take pictures with the guests and
[__] like it's crazy
it's insane
so that's what you take away
this isn't what I was thinking
you [__] ain't that cool
all these [__] podcast and I
thought were really cool there's a lot
of you [__] are lame a lot of
you fools are on your way out and a lot
of people are talking about nothing
we're talking about nothing but we care
about what the [__] we're talking about
and that's how I feel I feel like deaf
was tight as hell and then I'm just like
that's the ninth person that's told me
the same story about you you [__]
weirdo you [__] creep I thought
people were a lot cooler
and I'm not saying all podcasting I'm
just saying like
since we've been here that's the one
thing I've noticed like
nothing has changed I have to look at
the date on certain episodes to go oh
yeah that was it it's so much a part of
this this is exactly Who We Are
because I'm seeing other [__] I'm not
trying to like this part that's not what
I'm saying I don't really watch podcasts
I'm gonna say a lot of you [__]
aren't that cool I'm talking about
people that just do [__]
like for content
I just feel I don't know what I'm just
hard to say it it's more like to suck
money from the fans yeah yeah thank you
that's why I got pissed at Seth Rogen oh
about the story time yeah that that was
that but that was that whole point that
was different yeah so that's how sticky
that week is yeah see that's that Spidey
right there
Jesus Christ
um sorry I didn't mean to just sit here
and start talking [__] about people I
meant like okay how do I how do I work
this
you know when Happy Gilmore gets hit by
the bug and Shooter McGavin look he's
Human After All
that's how I feel about a lot of these
people even though I love having you
more way more than shooting McGavin if
he was Dick
I'm using an example like
you can do this just me and you
since we've been here for two years now
I'm like
this is me and Marty with a third of the
time of our life
what if we had a team
that's all I keep thinking like
that's what it takes to run the show
what if we had a [__] team helping us
Marty yeah what if we had a graphic
student we woke and we had
half of the [__] you do in your life
done
half of the clips are the clips
sick intro I'm sick there's an edit
thanks but we're still right there doing
it all like yo you got that change that
up a little bit and it's like I'm
actually very encouraged after all the
interviews because I felt I've
interviewed a lot of people I've had
eight interns through different colleges
through Jurassic Graphics I've had
multiple employees I've interviewed all
kinds of people
really love the passion and just like
the enthusiasm that I felt from
everybody that I interviewed just
through our direct Instagram from our
community and I feel like we're gonna
get that it's not that hard to do I mean
it is hard to find hard-working people
that's why this [__] has seemed so like
you know it's like not that big of a
deal but now that we know what we need
to do I feel really encouraged by
like 95 damn near 100 of the people I
interviewed I felt really great about
so that's really that sells a lot got it
that's what I meant to say I just worded
it better in my head not that you
[__] aren't that cool this is
what I meant
that's all you're doing
yeah the biggest show like that's like
not I'm not saying anything we're
talking about like all the shows we're
working with I'm saying everyone else
like
because like you see a lot of this stuff
on like forums so and so podcasts fired
this person or let this person go this
person went over here it's like wait
you guys got some interns helping you
oh yeah that's how I feel like yeah yeah
this is what I meant you guys aren't
that far away that I you guys aren't as
far as I thought yeah that's what I
meant like damn those shows are massive
bro one day I would love to be up there
like
we are there those numbers just aren't
the same we'll get those numbers one
okay
I'm more like
word
I'm trying to say it to where I don't
I'm not just [__] on people because
that's how I feel like I was saying
they're like you guys aren't that cool
what I'm saying is like that's all
you're doing it's just realizing we're
doing it too I'm not such the underdog
that I think it was [__] Marty Wordsmith
ass Marty why does that take so long for
me to [__] no yes
we're we're doing all right that's how I
feel like you [__] aren't that
far away like you're not Out Of Reach
that's how I feel not in the back that's
just how you think about yourself yeah
not in a bad way but like when I met
when I brought up her like some of you
[__] fools are creeps I was just
bring them Christmas that's a separate
conversation yeah I don't like that's
separate conversation that people just
like being in it to like leech money and
like [__] yeah man like I even told you
like yo we need to make money but also
money is not
ready when we talked about like I
wouldn't want to come back here did I
talk about we need to make more money
first no
I care about the show I care about
people commenting going damn
something's missing because if one
person said that 99 thought it and only
one was like I'll type it
oh people's time is so valuable yeah
just sit there for two years and watch
this build just to go
what happened to the show like what's
did that's why I feel like we're not
that far off so I I felt like I was I
was dwelling I'm like damn dude I said
that like an [__] just talking [__]
about other people that was two
different things that's why I couldn't
put it together thank you I didn't mean
to come out like 10 [__] you yeah don't
give a [__] about anybody like this is
ours don't be a creep and we just were
thinking that we were littler Yeah in
our production in our
overall production Yeah we actually were
and we're actually
Underground
but are we
like we're like the because you got to
be honest guys when it comes to
podcasting we're the smaller
of any show pretty small when it comes
like
mainstreamer shows but the thing is
every one of those shows fans I think
would like our show we just haven't met
them yet yeah they haven't met us yet
and I feel like don't worry we'll get
there and when we get there I feel like
they'll be like yo this the shows I can
relate to and I guarantee these fools
aren't going to do some weird [__] to
people and or try to get over on us and
I'll do some [__] dumb [__] let's be
[__] racist underneath or something
stupid as hell or disenchanted fans and
I've gotten screwed over by people that
turn out to be creeps ugh
we'll just do everywhere I go and meet
fans everywhere when I was in New York
and the MoMA how many like four Dudes
but bro I [__] love the show can't
get a picture yeah bro it's like every
Monday see I'm like
it's like more than just our little
internet thing I feel like when people
say like okay like I'll see you then
yeah gotta respect that that's like
everything I always wanted like oh my
God like an inside [__] yeah oh my God
I'm so like
[Music]
yeah that's what I've learned
that we're [__] on the right path
here
doing our own [__] that's a nice
lighting setup yeah it's beautiful the
warehouse is special it's like our world
in here
by ourselves yeah good tricked it's nice
because like the more I think about it's
like damn dude there's a lot of big
Productions out there like we're right
up there if not a little bit nice
and I'm not saying it to be an [__]
or gloat I'm saying it as a I didn't
know hard yeah like damn I didn't know
we were doing that good that's how I
feel like
good [__] so sorry what that was a long
rant you know rant City it's all good
yeah that's a great takeaway though it's
that level that you might be thinking is
out there right above you maybe like
maybe it's not maybe
maybe okay now hit it while you light it
now that you burn the front off
to be nervous one that's what these
things are [__] candidates Jesus
Christ This is
ASMR as mister
OG told me the other day that's not as
Mister stuff
he kept it he finally retained something
you can't go back he says he retained
asthma oh okay I said the [__] as Mr
[__] thank you good job you finally
remember some [__] that we talked about
no but this is
cereal milk listen to that airflow
it goes all the way in
we taste so much different when you dry
hit it versus when you hit it oh it
tastes a little bit on the black
licorice
weird okay next question Charlie 305
appreciate you this is Frank 4X
What would life be like without YouTube
would you still make career out of
cannabis or choose another one
a lot less stressful
or I should say like YouTube was just
like a regular platform if they're nice
to us it's all good
um
are you talking about more about weed
[__] I'm assuming but
honestly dude I
if I wasn't doing weed [__] or making
content I probably have like a couple
[__] children working for the city
or a government job because I know they
pay a lot
that's like what
before right before I started dating
Rosie I stopped smoking weed I was still
selling packs I saw smoke a weed because
my cousin my cousin works for the
government right
and he's an engineer
mechanical engineer for the government
he builds some [__]
and he's like yeah he's talking about
the janitor dude one of the janitors on
this floor and he goes man these Fool's
got it made I'm like what do you mean he
goes there's one guy on each floor one
does trash and one does floors one of
those windows there's no one guy does
all could you imagine getting paid 42 an
hour to come in and change the trash
cans in the bathroom of
government employees a lot of people are
tagging on the walls and [__]
yeah so I'm like how what the [__] did
you just say because dude they start at
30. it goes stop it you go can I and
that's when I was selling packs I was
[__] 21.
22 I'm like
I will work there right now
because I always thought I thought it
was 30 an hour I did the math I'm like
how long would it take me to buy a house
at like 400 000 and I was doing all the
math like
years three years to buy a [__] house
that's all I was thinking like oh my God
I can buy a house but I was 25. okay
that's where I need to be yeah like this
week is cool I never made content my
life so you know and um
he's those but they take veterans
automatically you might get denied a few
times I go so you're telling me how to
join the [__] army goes no no just
join the Air Force like are you kidding
me they'll join the Air Force
do two years come out and get the job
I'm like are you [__] dumb because
are you dumb
and I sat there and thought about it for
like two days
and I was like all right I'll do it so I
smoke a weed I told my cousin all right
I'm gonna sign up then I told him I'm
gonna lose [__] 30 pounds and then
I'm gonna go [__] sign up
I was gonna give myself two months to
work out and go sign up
anyway
the next week I started dating Rosie
I wasn't smoking weed
hold on hold on this timeline is weird
no no this timeline's weird because I
was getting high as [__] when me and
Rosie started dating
oh that's right I stopped smoking weed
and this is way before
I started dating Rosie sorry it's before
I started dating Rose me and I were
hanging out all the [__] time that's
what happened
and then right when I started dating I
started smoking again
that's what happened oh weird you know
why I couldn't imagine leaving and not
being able to hang out with Rosie is why
I was like
why am I gonna go away and I can't even
hang out with Rosie I need to choose a
different path in my life it's changed
that's that's why I didn't go
um anyway I stopped smoking weed I
started going to the gym in the morning
and at night
I lost that weight fast as [__] then
again I wasn't even that heavy but still
I was ready to go
and then I just was like you know what
I'd rather chill Rosie then go to the
[__] Air Force and sign the
government my name like no thank you I
just could I was just thinking house by
25. I'm with it let's do this
I need a teenager I think like only
because not for the government's gonna
buy the job I'm gonna go work for the
[__] government's en janitor I was
like I'll be a janitor right now how
much did you [__] say he's like this
guy's working for 30 years so he's about
to retire
never bent over his life just as Windows
like
oh oh what'd you say yeah let me get
that he's like but you can't smoke we're
gonna go what about after I get there he
goes now you smoke weed oh [__] so just
don't get hurt go I'm sure I'll be okay
watch the windows all right so that was
my life it was going to be Air Force
that's crazy to think about man
so happy I didn't go anyway
um that's where I'd be without YouTube
all right I think I mean not YouTube
it's just the internet
I would be uh
to do a graphic
maybe yeah but I think I want I want to
like teach though I've always wanted to
teach
so coach and [__] like that so about to
get into that now I will say you're
doing that too real quick one thing I
don't know if you can zoom in on the
camera to edit but you are aggressive
with your weed you want to know why I
can tell why ready watch this
okay
I don't even think you should put your
hand on the ground
that shit's a [__] litter bomb over
there I think it's so funny it looks
like your [__] exploded there's [__]
ashes and Embers all over your side
I thought that was normal
wow yeah I'm like this though I do this
Mash I just twist to keep that line plus
I'm talking my ass off so I'm not like
power hitting my bad my bad I just
wanted to point out I thought it was
[__] hysterical
all right on to the next question this
is Kristen kinda blumen
okay I really hope I said that right
what would you say is the best way to
find smart and motivated individuals to
surround yourself by ready listen to
this question
preferably Stoners I'm having a hard
time finding people who like to work but
also play hard work hard but also play
hard like I want you know I yeah many
that I know are either party animals who
don't like have much going on or people
that are straight edge any advice
question
what a question
I have
oh I have that problem too you're the
dude to ask I have that problem too
I I my homies are my homies they're cool
people not everybody's ready to step
that [__] up
and um this past year I've decided to
not care anymore and just focus on
things I'm doing they put like 70 of my
time into other people
in my head you know I mean like oh I got
into this and get that
and if it's not reciprocated and or like
bro where's the motive I just know if I
if I was doing normal [__] my friend was
started like doing some cool [__] and I
like doing that too I take advantage of
that they're like yo I'll set you up do
everything I'll pay for it what do you
want to do
and I didn't act on it that's my [__]
fault that's crazy yeah
it's like your connect yo you can come
in here
I'll give you a free ounce every time
you come but we got to learn something
every time and you never went to that
connect again you're a [__] [__]
that's a good idea yeah I always say I'm
like come on now we're gonna do is smoke
weed and business plan like and you
don't want that and I'm not saying
anybody in particular I'm just saying
General people in my life
I tried I feel like you're forcing it
now I've told certain people maybe 15
times in the more than 15 times when are
you ready
so I'm good
I'm over that
um
but that question is [__] incredible
because me and Rosie do not hang out
with people we hang out with like four
people because we're busy
also I don't know people I want to try
to let people into my I don't know what
their intentions are style type of thing
because I don't know them they might
know who I am and I'm not saying that's
an arrogant thing I'm just saying I
don't know who everyone is to get in to
hang out with you
it's going to be a minute it's hard to
make friends as an adult oh yeah it is
it's it isn't it isn't I just have my
guard all the way up because I'm like
well do you think you're gonna rob me
I'll shoot you I think my head like
I don't know you
that's why I only have people that I
meet through other people really
I don't really meet new [__] people
ever yeah it's hard dude it's really
hard to trust [__]
I don't see myself ever dressed I was
like we had Cam's birthday party and
stuff like I ever see me just hanging
out with the dad imagine me just going
and hanging out with a regular dad just
[__] hanging out why not it just I
don't know they were cool I'm sure they
would be fine I don't know no I made
some cool I've been some cool ass food
like like we were saying uh did I talked
about earlier [__] Fernando she's
probably in the chest Fernando you
borrow I met him through the chat
he's cool so I was like yeah I'll be in
La one day I'm not saying this like I'm
gonna hang out with everybody the reason
I did because I talked to him for like
two years
let's meet up and then we make it in the
warehouse he was [__] awesome and
last night he came by and we [__]
smoked we and they went back home until
Chicago he's waiting on his flying my
fool come by Let's get high as [__] give
him his first Rising dab like I told you
it was pretty cool yeah yeah and uh
like that that's one of the only people
I have met that's new that I don't know
or any connection with
because like I don't it's hard for me to
hang out with people because then again
I really don't hang out
like if you see me hang out with John a
lot it's because like you don't smoke a
ticket to dab or two I'm like
yeah I'll see you in a little bit I'll
come by he's a block away so what's that
tune about like you guys like there's no
get up every morning type shows on his
no not at all that feels busy I'm
[__] busy he's got two children and
[__] like no I probably go I probably
twice a week and he was a block away
okay yeah yeah but uh no that was going
to like every morning going to a boxing
gym and [__] and I'm about to go with
him on Thursday and start so we'll
probably get a better like take a dab in
the morning go guess throw up in the
[__] box and uh
yes I'm gonna start I'm gonna start
going with him to that
but yeah no no
for fall we're all business [__] but no
we chill we chill if I can sick he's
blocked away we'll just hang on taking
some batteries are you guys doing like
[__] tiptoeing across the logs and
[__] I saw
oh no we went on a hike
oh here's a this quick thing I went on a
hike right and I'll just say this
I don't know what's been going on with
me but I feel like I couldn't jump over
something if I tried I feel like I got
no spring in my body there's no athletic
bone left I feel like unorganized
character yeah and I was walking and I
was hiking I'm like
yeah even though I had to go on the
treadmill I'm working on my house I
don't feel like I could jump bring my
knees in my chest and [__] land like
I don't have that spring I don't know
what's wrong dude
and I was hiking I was like
[__] yeah like just behind these [__]
whatever why I was like
oh bro I feel bomb I saw the log I was
like
run across that [__] right now and then
telling them like damn walk across and
like I'll do it right now like yeah
right bro it's a log
I didn't I had my phone in my pocket I
didn't want to show off and be a dummy
but I was gonna start doing my [__]
football things across state where you
do the one foot over the back one foot
like bro I got this but I was crossing
like
dude I feel I'm like hyped right now and
then I cross back and we're hitting
these [__] I was running up the
[__] Hills with John my bro I feel
bomb and the next morning I even told
Rosie this morning I feel like I can
jump off upstairs I feel like I can jump
and yesterday before I I told you before
I ran
I stretched for like 35 minutes
yeah that's a long-ass time I got bored
as hell but I was stretching parts of my
legs I haven't stretched since like PE
as a kid I was going so deep in these
stretches I was pouring sweat like yoga
and [__] but I felt like something left
like that gross FernGully Blackness [__]
took off out of my body I feel so much
[__] better like I can jump over the
table were you watching a video or just
stretching however you felt like I was
listening to the new Future album
because I haven't heard it I was always
future got to say it's all PP I was like
what the [__] is going on as I was
stretching yeah what the hell and then I
think anybody that knows anything about
this stuff
would say you'd be like of course
oh my God that feels so much better
Marty I feel like I could [__] press
my own body open up your body you can
get locked down in your that's how I
feel [__] that's how I feel like
and then I just what I stretch so
[__] deep that's how I feel like my
lungs open
so anyway yeah I was running across the
log the other day that's what you saw
online it's [__] up because the more
you work out and exercise the more your
legs like need to be adjusted and like
stretched yeah
but if you don't it's even worse and you
can't even run
yeah so yeah I don't know where that was
way off so are you guys doing like a 5k
or some shot oh yeah I forgot I'm gonna
do a 5k next month so like three or four
miles I don't know but my mom's gonna do
it Rocco's gonna do it
me I think my mom's boyfriend's gonna do
it Rosie John his wife in San Francisco
no
I think it's
like in Calabasas oh Rosie has her
marathon in San Francisco
yeah bro I'm kind of nervous for her to
run through the streets of Frisco right
now I don't know if you guys know Chris
is not looking too hot
look at a little Armageddon yeah so
I don't know but yeah I don't know what
the [__] question was
oh how do you find people yeah I don't
know if you do how did that happen I
don't know
I don't know see look at that's our
conversation
in the middle right it's branched off
and then it goes all the weed hit me a
little and then I started thinking of
like damn dude do you think they sell
gak still for Nicholas and then it goes
to well one time when I was eating this
thing at the Spurs and then that's it
all right now we're like toward the
middle of like the the bronchial this
[__] is crazy I didn't even really look
at it it's sick it's like Rorschach test
it's mirrored it's dope yeah yeah I love
it
um okay if you find people they'll
you'll find them
that's all I can say it will eventually
be around them
I think the live chat is a good place to
sample a hard working weed smoking
people and I think I think I'm very
proud that our show tells people to work
hard which is [__] awesome I mean if
YouTube could just get past that and
accept that it's a motivational comedy
podcast I think maybe oh my God I never
thought of it that's how I always pitch
a comedy podcast yeah
that's the whole point that's the vibe
that's happened to I love that yeah
that's [__] cool
motivational comedy podcast will tell
you to get up and get and get done while
saying because things that are actually
motivational are unintentional like how
you just realize that yeah they're
unintentional yeah always actually
that's your weird motivational speaker
here we go
last one this is just a quick one
this is from Mr gas station and it says
will you ever do a collab with suicide
boys what's this SB
so suicide Boys you've never really
heard them right highly requested all
right so suicide boys are hard as [__]
I'm listening for long ass time Omar
knows them right
ratchet man
um
I'm not going to say all of it but my
homie Charlie reached out because
they're doing something I won't say in
case I'm not supposed to but they're
going to do a project
and I'm gonna help curate it because of
my knowledge in the field are they weed
dudes
um I don't know and I don't want to go
too into it because I don't know what I
can I don't know what they you know put
out there but it's a project
and they want me to help cure it okay
and I told their guy the manager I'm
like yeah yeah let me know
I'll do it for free
just let me get that interview on my
show wow
Beautiful Suicide boys do not do shows
they do not do podcasts they are hard
hardest to get just like Earl's
sweatshirt would be hard to get on this
show those are so we have a better time
and an easier time getting Drake on here
than we do Earl sweatshirts because they
don't truly give a [__]
like I don't care about doing the show
yeah I'm going to make my music we got
uh the dude from atmosphere oh [__]
Aunt first time he's ever been on the
interview yeah
but you see what I'm saying like yeah
but it's that's how hard I think it is I
think I can have the better time getting
Drake on here
an easier time getting Drake on here
than we would suicide boys and they're
not saying it in terms of sales or
coolness yeah I'm saying in the terms of
the usefuls really don't do interviews
they did one I think they did no jumper
and I'm not saying like people are like
yo they did 12 interviews already you're
[__] stupid
I'm talking about like real deal
interviews that we know of that I can
Google right now go oh not some obscure
2 000 [__] views from six years ago
how are you doing like I want we're the
plays for that though and I don't mean
views means everything in terms of like
it wasn't like on a [__] mic on a
phone hey what's up man you better go on
stage like not real sit down interview
with talk about their lives [__]
stories what's going on in your [__] how
would you like to be remembered like I
want [__] to sit down and go
this is what I want to talk about this
is where I want my fans to like be to
sit with and let it absorb that's how I
would like each guest to come on you're
like every guest that's left the [__]
spot has always said that was [__]
fun every single [__] time so I'm
proud of that for sure and I told you
the other day I think my problem is I'm
trying to
let the guests in on what we're doing
but it's not the guess I'm trying to
talk to I'm trying to talk to the fans
so what is it that they want to know
about more than it is remember I said
that the other day I'm like I feel like
I'm trying to appease the guest when we
were over there because they was like oh
big thing we haven't talked to you at
all your management talking to our
management and all this [__] and it was
so impersonal yeah so I felt like yo you
know this is what we do so if it felt
like we were being airing like this is
what we do no we're trying to we just
met that person six seconds true before
they [__] press play
that's so true how many times people are
you guys
a lot a lot almost 90 yeah so
that's a different Dynamic definitely
walking into our world here we opened
the door you knew who we were we coming
you want some drink you knew what you
were coming on type of [__] yeah when we
walk acid we walk them through our [__]
come in oh that's where we get high at
yo that's all right this is Jay Z yeah
yeah and walked through like Oswald film
story times just some [__] I do tell
stories and get [__] up anyway come in
here yeah all your homies can sit right
here you guys want some water yeah it's
us doing that [__] which is cool
and like over there wasn't us but it was
like oh they came in and sat down
immediately like hey by the way my name
is my name is Thomas
yeah you know yeah it's different it's
different yeah
so I don't know where we're going with
that I'm officially in rant
City over here I don't even know where I
was at with that holy [__] what is it
was a question oh suicide boys yeah yeah
so yeah hopefully hopefully all right we
posted that [__] went on crazy on
Instagram when we posted it I remember
you know how hyped I'd be just to ask
some questions
because you guys gotta remember how we
talked about what did we talk about when
we said we what we got from the studio
like yo we got to talk yeah okay DJ drop
I got my credit show album signs like we
[__] now we're chilling with
Professor like that we're basically
friends like did you hear that we're
happy we are fans of people too and
that's what I think earlier this is some
of you [__] aren't that cool
some of you [__] think you're
too cool
we are have a huge fan base we are also
[__] fans of people so why can't we
show that
like why can't we I went to the end of
the atmosphere because I didn't want to
[__] geek out it was hard oh we we I
since found all three songs
um
I thought one was a different one and it
wasn't at all and you know what's crazy
one of the songs that's its Trilogy I
should have known I have those lyrics
stuck in my head every time I really try
to drive on the freeway because it's a
it's part of the song I'm like bro
I always say these lines in my head
Brandon I don't know if you do like
totally you see a word ago and then that
line from one of your songs goes right
it's random that one pops off a lot
I'm like bro how did I not piece it
together oh
two of the people in the car is the guy
that got hit by the truck and I'm like
it's the oh how did I I know that song
by heart how did I not [__] anyway
the other one was harder way harder it
was from the view of the bystander
watching the accident you should make a
video about this for you Planet clipping
some man hair scalp and skull
here is the first song I originally and
then I mean uh slug said there's a drill
it's a trilogy
I should have known I should have known
uh scalp I should have known that right
off the bat okay that's the high school
and then three song names gotcha and
those are the true that's the oh they're
all a Trilogy okay that makes sense it's
from the two people that died in the car
versus the guy his what he was doing got
hit by a by a couple of drunks the drunk
people in the car and the people
watching two cars Collide and die Jesus
and I know all those songs and it's like
how did I not piece it what
what span of time were the like 10 years
oh [__] okay
now that he's not here I can be all
geeked out that motherfucker's a
Wordsmith yeah are you [__] are you
hating on that you thought you know
would be sick
continuation or maybe even a different
perspective of that that night
what you're a [__] baller I love
slugs so damn how many of those little
things is he sprinkled throughout
because a lot of there's a lot of
different little Easter eggs if you hear
and you
call that I mean a lot of people do that
but come on so that's what we got out of
there you know what we had some of the
[__] most fun episodes
we had some of the best episodes we ever
had we've tuned ourselves in as hosts so
I said we mixed that hybrid of like
being mad on our [__] with the guest
because what what I felt was we were
trying to interview people also impress
our new [__] like yeah this is
what we do yeah
thanks for having us
thanks guys but yeah we're we
interviewed the [__] out of him right
right yo that was crazy [__] yeah thanks
guys because we're just like yo this is
us we're also not just High there is
kind of that too for sure because I'm
not saying anybody said that because
they all smoke yeah I also didn't want
anybody going damn these new
[__] are hot and [__] that's
why I was on top of my [__] my girl
we're trying to like die on it we're
about to like do some different [__] and
we're like I don't like this difference
I hate this [__] that's how I felt like
I loved it and and didn't like the fact
that I had to go hello
even though I like doing that I don't
like it when that's the point of it yeah
the point of it is to be cleaner and
tidier
that's not our Direction
ultimately we're not that
clean Super commercial if I was gonna do
that it would have been I would have
made a lot of money a lot sooner from
certain people yeah I was like y'all do
what you want
we'll take the [__] long road yep
also I'm happy let's build this [__]
back up also real quick right now
um oh that was the end of the fan
questions thank you very much thank you
guys so much what was the name last one
just want to say it again one more time
Mr gas station thank you guys very much
yeah I asked that on Instagram all right
boom over the page Instagram this is our
Instagram right here make sure to go
follow that [__] you ready oh yeah okay
guys before we move on something super
important we completely got demonetized
on this channel and our Clips Channel
so what we did is we had to wipe and
delete our entire Clips Channel
everything
which really hurt it sucks but also we
have every one of those clips still we
can just redo it we just had to wipe it
so we can try to get remonetized so if
you could do us a favor we had to start
over even though we have 70 000 almost
followers they said you need 4 000 watch
time again and how what else four
thousand watch time minutes and we got
the subs so like nope start over but if
it's a wiped Channel how do you get
watch time minutes
so it's like for no [__] reasons
but it's okay we live and learn and you
know what we're going to get over it and
we'll never do that mistake again so
what we need you to do right now if you
can do us the biggest [__] favor if
you are in this chat when you're done go
to this channel boom dope as usual Clips
or is it don't use your podcast Clips
yeah adobe's usual podcast Clips go
watch that channel go leave a comment if
you're just like in the bathroom taking
a [__] and you don't want to be on your
phone which is not going to happen
you're going to be on your phone just
watch some clips if you're going to
sleep or some [__] you're like yo my
phone won't turn off leave a clip on if
you're at work and should watch a clip
that would be badass thank you to
anybody if you can't just go like all
the videos there's like seven
and we all of them were no smoking
videos we're trying to get monetized
again all right we think the kids
channel can be super strong and we
weren't utilizing it before because
we're like no we're gonna have a team
take over and then you know
you guys heard about that so
here we are saying go help us with that
clip Channel we don't say this often but
we need your help for real
gold over there please like help us out
when does this uh episode drop
what's the date
it's not the first right
right now shout out to Tommy G Tommy G's
the man uh I told Marty a couple maybe
like a month ago that there's a guy no
no a week ago I was telling Rosie about
a month or two two months ago I saw this
rapper 29 his name is blp kosher he's a
rapper that looks like he's straight out
of Florida with his grip he looks like
white Kodak huh Kodak white he looks
like Kodak white all right and
I think he's amazing I love that he's
embracing his Jewish side while rapping
while being from Florida with the golds
I love it I love this phone and his
lyrics are kind of hard I really like
his music I I know a lot of people are
very shocked like you listen to BLB
closure yeah he's hard and I love it
Eddie skates get the [__] out of here
this was a all-around human being I want
to chill with so
um Tommy G sent him sent him all of our
information like yo when you're in L.A
he's gonna be in La the first to the
third for his shows or whatever he's all
Tommy G sentences I'll shout out to
Tommy G for it texting him he texts I'm
like yo go hang out if you're gonna do
any show in La come through Marty Thomas
and really chill come hang out and he
said hell yeah I'll hit him up so just
in case go to blp kosher's uh Instagram
all right go let him know go on the dope
as usual podcast when you're in La we
would appreciate that all right we don't
have um booking agents anymore
where you know we went to the agency
we're getting the biggest yeah
hey hey there this is our booking agent
right here okay
I love it so
hold on I got you don't re-light that
you just dug to I don't ever
comforted ashes I had never seen that
kid before he's great yeah I love him
bro and then I just saw a video
yesterday I'm like beautiful just like
hard flip I'm
locked in
coolest dude ever I need to talk to him
he seems so deep that's what my friends
look like as a bunch of white kids that
were not preppy white kids these little
kind of ghetto but not like with big ass
[__] drugs and no grills but it's
like he just reminds me of Ryan
just like Fool's freestyle getting
[__] up skating that's when I saw him
skating I'm like bro I need to I need to
talk to you we need you on the show I'll
have my phone out still in an [__]
sorry
um blp coach you go to Instagram say go
on the dope as usual podcast when you
come to La he's coming to do a show all
right let him know to come out how would
you describe his music that was the type
of [__] is yeah honestly dude it's like
Southern
ah
yeah it's like I feel like it's more
like Southern not you can't say pop
music but it's not gangster music gotcha
it's not like
hyped music
18 or is he 25 I have no clue you can't
tell I can't tell yeah
um but he seems awesome so yeah if you
can do us a favor that's how we got
Steelo Brim on here how many guests did
we get because of the fans so many so
many we made a post on our Instagram go
tag so and so and how many people
actually sat down here a lot dude
so I love when there's somebody who I
don't know about and then like
bam turns out all the [__] fans
already know about him and love them and
I had no clue this dude has this whole
[__] thing going on it's crazy yeah
there's so many different Lanes people
can thrive in so stop hanging the GB or
young life GB is killing a two right now
yeah he's doing a great job he's really
doing a good job
I just saw this thing up and coming
rappers to look out for and it popped a
little Tick Tock flashed Merced
California cheap yeah I'm like shut up
and it popped up like yo this is the
best version it said it Merced CA [__]
out of here people don't know when they
come on the show I'm rooting for you for
[__] for life
forever forever I hope you do wonderful
things you were so tight and I hope your
career flourishes
because why not what I I don't watch
other shows I can come and hate on you
yeah I'm special like then you see them
out there killing it especially when
somebody is their first interview and
show like that especially for that one
with Indian having the [__] Merced on
his arms and [__] bro I love those
tattoos he's too hard how long we've
been here real quick
142. oh we're gonna be here for three
hours
strap in I gotta roll more weed and I'll
do it right here while we're talking
because we're we're only two notes yeah
oh we're only two notes in so I'm gonna
skip ahead a little bit
Marty was out here running
all right Marty's out here running and I
was running Marty can you tell everybody
what you did two weeks ago
well
I wouldn't shut the [__] up about it for
a long time we're talking about this OC
Marathon
we haven't had the show the show hasn't
really been here for four months
I remember that I think a lot of fans
kind of tuned out a little bit so so
four months ago so like yeah so January
really right around Ted Talk yeah yeah I
decided I wanted to do the marathon
just to put something a bigger challenge
out in front of [__] time oh okay
sounds awesome
we just dropped the Ted Talk Vlog on the
double Channel too by the way we did the
audio version with a little Ted Talk
Montage we didn't really film too much
just because we were still actively
learning our speeches before prior to
going on stage and [__]
so when I was working out and get ready
for that I decided I'm listening to Dave
and got David Goggins book and I'm like
you know what I'm gonna do a [__]
Marathon why not it seems impossible it
seems silly
might as well be
something else to be working for here in
the gym and shut
so then I was like maybe I'll just do a
half marathon and in the book right as
I'm kind of thinking that thought
Goggins is like [__] talk about
should I just start off with a half
marathon why oh my God damn he's right
why the [__] would you just do the half
marathon and I had like
I had already been kind of training
since like November so I had like five
or six months and I just said I'm just
gonna do it
so I just kind of became my lifestyle
kind of like every day just becoming a
runner because I'm not a runner figuring
out how to stretch how to
try to balance not being injured because
if you go run go run 10 15 miles outside
and try not to be injured even if you're
already in great shape you're gonna it's
not that easy real quick see what we got
here just smell it
oh my gosh
that's what I did I smiled my eyes
closed it almost smells like a like a
tropical
but it's gassy
it's sweet tropical drink to get a
resort
like a pina colada or some [__] wow
that's amazing this whatever they got
going right now is some Next Level [__]
cause
sorry she have to shower for these super
sick jars but also inside of the jars
she had the cbx because this is
the system that's this is immaculate
yeah that's some of the best weed I've
ever seen so this is what we're gonna do
first time ever yeah you know what this
is what we're gonna do guys I'm Gonna
Save this video since we're not buying
my YouTube's laws and uh we'll let
overlay this so you can see there you
are back into here bam this weed is so
frosted
Preposterous it's purple that's that
should be called Preposterous Kush
look
I it's incredible you can barely even
rip it apart because it's so it's too
sticky it's like barely even comes apart
this is ridiculous
oh as a photographer I looked at and I
was like bro where the [__] is my camera
boom I'm saving that putting it to the
side for the first time we've never done
that that was kind of awesome because
they're gonna go straight into the jar
from this shot oh I like that all right
here we go but anyway
yeah so about the last month out I just
started heavy running stop lifting just
focusing on and then yeah we had the
marathon so
I think really A lot of it was just
mental just meant because once I mean I
had already decided no matter what I was
gonna there was no way I wasn't
finishing but you have like a seven hour
limit so there is that window and I just
it was all about just trying to find a
pace and I just really didn't know what
to expect like I said I'm not a runner
so we had to get up at like 2 30 in the
morning be out there at like four hit
the little shuttle to the set of the
starting line was unnecessary I sat at
the starting line for an hour and a half
oh just cold kind of stretching out and
[__] waiting for the [__] to start
and then it was really beautiful though
once once it kicked off
everybody want and it was still dark out
but we started going through Newport
Beach and started at Fashion Island and
went right right away through the
neighborhoods along the ocean
and I would just had a quick pace for
like the first probably eight miles I
was like damn I might get a good time
you know you finished with a great time
though I'm not I was thinking like I you
know I might I might finish [__] fast
I'm I'm doing pretty just let me let me
finish okay okay
I was sprinting along really good right
along the ocean through all the
neighborhoods all the neighbors are out
in the streets with their coffee
cheering people out with signs
throughout the first you know the whole
time really which was really cool it was
also like I wanted to be like thank you
thank you but you can't really talk yeah
you can't really you know you just gotta
kind of stay in the zone and then um I
would say right around the where the
halfway the half marathon and the full
Marathon split at this big ass Hill so
if you're doing the half you went left
and if you're doing the full you went up
this big ass Hill and that was kind of
the point maybe like a little bit past
that where it was like really really
difficult to keep [__] going and I
just had uh really really power through
to just keep moving forward and then
probably about this
20 mile Mark everybody was kind of
really power walking and my legs were
just like frozen up so I was like
like power jog walking for a long
stretch of that my legs wouldn't bend
completely Frozen up and I didn't really
have a concept of where I was at time
wise because my watch died
so I was like
not really knowing where I was but
there's a lot of different kind of
methods of thinking about this what
worked for me was getting a really
getting in far ahead fast so that you
can swim my legs locked up which was
inevitable I had already I was already
at a good like uh miles per hour rate or
whatever so you could finish yeah so I
could finish off even though those last
miles were rough and ugly and I was not
in like good form running whatsoever
um you know we still finished strong
there was a dude that broke the record
and finished in like two hours 50
minutes or some 26 mile race guys
26 mile marathon so if you're wondering
eight mile 12 yeah it's 26 miles Rosie
ran it and uh my business partner and
our homie business partner's wife Sammy
and our homie Sammy she uh also ran it
party you finished in five hours and 50
minutes
40 to be exact five four
are you [__] me that's fast dude
it's crazy I was sitting there
with his entire family
we're scoping waiting for Marty to cross
we all don't see Marty and then I see a
guy I'm like damn that guy kind of looks
like Marty but he's got to be a huge
like a burglar I was like he's dressed
like a [__] burglar I don't think
it's Marty Marty was gonna be wearing
something blue or something I
think about it yeah I didn't realize I
was dressed like a stealth [__]
operative
all pitch black
everything the only thing with color was
your body everything else was covered in
black black tape black beanie black
glasses it was coincidence because I
didn't even think about what I was
really gonna wear
it was ridiculous we're all sitting
there at the Finish Line his daughter
that means she has a little sign
[Music]
we all look and you're Crossing us we
didn't get no picture of you cry and
then Justin caught one
first of all it was so awesome having
all you guys there at the Finish Line oh
dude we got there my damn Mardi Gras
fast as hell that's what I thought I'm
like I'm gonna get there early just in
case but you crossed 10 minutes after I
got there I was shocked oh [__] I was
like what the [__] I did not feel like I
was making great time I felt very like
sloppy towards the end but I mean pound
for pound like this is something regular
people can do like it seems very
impossible one mile seems wildly
impossible to somebody who's not like
used to running yeah but once you get I
found that like it's mentally no matter
what no matter how much you're training
that first two miles your mind's gonna
try to stop you with everything it has
even if you got great momentum going
your mind is gonna give you everything
it has that's how you stop once you get
past that first two miles you can kind
of go
like it really opens up if you can keep
a pace it's all about just pacing your
breath keeping your heart rate under
control and just keeping a nice smooth
steady Pace be mindful of your where
your feet are landing and you can go out
there and do way more than you think you
can
and that's just this is just one thing
in life but running it sucks like a lot
of people say damn I can't [__] run
to you know whatever I feel like that
too kind of I feel like you know like
also but I put my mind to it and just
did it just to do it you know like my
sister-in-law is like why like at the
end of it when I [__] Frozen and
couldn't get up the bleachers and
couldn't sit down and [__] it's just
like it's just it's good to challenge
yourself now I know I can yeah
then you guys see something funny
motivational podcast motivational comedy
podcast yeah
well if I was like and if you think you
can do it you can push yourself like
damn where it was motivational as [__]
yeah it's important I mean if we're
gonna have a show and you know if we're
gonna do [__] like we just want to like
be the best versions of ourselves so I'm
gonna try to push myself to just
whatever I told Marty missions absurdly
buff yeah he should that'd be [__]
hilarious well you imagine Marty's being
[__] rock John Cena
Yeah for real could you imagine like
sorry co-host
hey man
I mean next up it seems even more
impossible than the marathon which is
the dunk
which is the dunk I love the way you
said that this weed is so sticky all I
do is break it up oh I might have to go
wash my [__] hands it's like you
we're playing with a glue stick or some
[__] yeah no that [__] is glued
there's no doubt about it that [__] is
some of the glueiest stinky let's see
let's see let's see of all time
[__] jar
damn
that's the new test oh [__]
do you see this guys
that is a high quality glass jar right
there
high quality 420.
are you kidding me that was pretty cool
wow damn okay that's impressive that was
[__] impressive as it was
okay here we go all right Rosy because
the like you know I was [__] up for a
good three days afterwards where life
was not I mean it wasn't as bad as I
thought it was going to be but I also
couldn't really walk normally at all the
idea that she was doing three of these
inside like a month and a half two
months and a half marathon and [__]
five cans half of that is insane
it's not even there the next morning she
worked however they're trading that's
crazy told her to slow down that's crazy
that isn't yeah like
I attribute a lot of uh not feeling
super horrible to stretching 100 yeah
and getting adjusted by the chiropractor
going into it and not trying to like I
don't know it felt good to just kind of
plan it out map it out really for the
first time
put my mind or something
just go do it just for the sake of doing
it
yeah so by the end of the year the goal
is to dunk a basketball and that will
involve me getting [__] jacked
hopefully there we go you got it because
Professor told me it's all course
trained it's not about your leg strength
so we're gonna find out here we go we'll
see
by The Freshman the professor the guy we
met that we know now I'm stuck still
he's so cool I love the professor and
he's so nice
um
oh damn we're barely halfway okay
guys up next
I'll give you a little story a little
story time while I roll this joint you
ready
Rosie her favorite rapper is Lil Wayne
always has been since I've known her
we've never gone to Lil Wayne concert
she's never seen him so we're like you
know what
let's go Rosie got these tickets like a
month ago apparently they're really hard
to get it's his last show it's here in
LA
they're getting resold already all that
[__] right
so
Rosie gets these tickets guy sells them
to us guy tries to buy it back two days
later
we bought him for like 700 bucks they
owned up going for like 20 hundred
dollars
on the stupid resale [__] right
so I'm like oh damn this show's about to
be crazy people are excited it has a
smaller venue
I'm gonna do this the show's probably
gonna be insane if they're charging like
the resale's like that this must be nuts
I
haven't been to a concert that of people
I didn't know of already like people I
didn't know like
I know of Lil Wayne that's what I'm
saying
like uh last concert I went before covet
it was all Earth Gang my homie manages
Earth Gang like I haven't been to a
concert where I'm waiting in line and
getting a ticket [__] because I don't
like being in crowds of people
all right that's that's why I'm not
saying like I'm not cool or I'm too cool
I'm allergic to wheat you can hear it
did you hear it
oh God
I'm getting Wheezy sorry
anyway getting a little Weezy yeah oh
I'm getting a little Wheezy talking
about a little easy here we go wow
Wordsmith
sorry everybody's driving also be safe I
haven't said that in a long time
um
real quick sorry for that I had to drink
some water I'm still just dying
that is some [__] potent flower too
son that's gonna anything is gonna get
them allergies going is that [__] try
not to have an asthma attack here um
so the reason I say that is because like
I know I'm gonna go sit in my seat
and you know be around shoulder I just
only being shoulders I don't go to the
theater and if I pick them online if
there's people already next to me like I
don't want to sit right next to people
because my fear is like don't be rude
because I'm gonna have to beat the [__]
out of you
and I don't want to get a conversation
with anybody I always feel like
someone's gonna be rude to me
damn so fear I have like don't be
[__] rude to me I'm gonna be nice to
you yeah but if you're rude to me and
I'm nice to you I'ma feel played and
beat the [__] out of you so like I don't
want that at all so I'm like I always
feel weird at concerts and unless I'm
backstage my homie or something I'm like
oh yeah I could smoke I'm just gonna
watch your show you know it's different
I don't have to be in a crowd where
fools are fighting yeah and getting
shit-faced can I tell you the biggest
power move we got the box seats for the
WNBA game oh bomb so it's like you're
the only people up there but yeah we
basically had the whole [__] to
ourselves damn near it was [__]
awesome you just got to go to the
off-brand [__] but then you get to have
the whole sweet to yourself boom not to
mention they brought up the
[__] vice president crazy
and Brittany greiner's first game back
which was [__] I didn't even realize
before we even went to the game damn
near like hours before the game I
realized oh that's who they're playing
oh this is our first game back this is a
season opener oh [__]
so I'm just [__] watching her shoot
around and should imagine how she's
feeling she's in a [__] Russian
prison as an American When The War
kicked off and [__] oh I didn't even
think about the war part of that
and they just got you over there but oh
damn she was back they got their ass
whooped though they went out there and
got smacked by the Sparks I like that
it was weird seeing the [__] but I
didn't even know Kamal Harris was coming
out [__] she just
presidential strolling [__] out in the
floor
I had my daughter and her friend they
felt bawling in the [__] Staple
Center VIP [__] oh hell yeah shit's dope
up there that that in and of itself just
made it worth it you know like even
though it was a blowout and [__] but
even those blow out
the fundamentals so the point is you go
get those forty dollar [__] videos
and fall out for your kids they were
forty dollars for the boxy stop it for
the season opener
all right let's move
that's unable they were forty dollars
only and the whole ship
like a piece I mean I got it I brought
it I get it a piece I get you
a couple months ago
yeah
that's that's
the cheap life sorry
those Sparks players aren't making a lot
of money and I mean yeah that's why they
have to play over season shut in the
officers damn
that's sad yeah I looked it up is that I
mean you got to have a second job if
you're [__] in the WNBA I think
that's like UFC fighters basically
that's not right
um sorry holy [__]
Lil Wayne yep oh damn wow look at me I
remember what the [__] we were talking
about let's go I only sit by people
because I feel like they're gonna be
rude to me anyway uh
sit in the little windshield you know
like you know what we'll get the tickets
cool we're set I just don't like going
to show like I said I'm not trying to be
bougie I'm just don't
like being around people's shit-faced
drunk so many people are passing out
before the show started lol I'm like
yeah that's why I'd hate being in
concerts damn it
would be around a bunch of people on
drugs and [__] I mean drugs are cool
people not hail or shrunk [__] stuff
there yeah they don't handle their
[__] drugs anyway we're sitting there
I'm at the Lil Wayne show
Rosie's Ultra excited Lil Wayne comes
out her favorite rapper her favorite
rapper we're on the
the balcony
it's like an old building I have a fear
of heights I'm around a bunch of people
and I feel the ground just
giving a little but I'm sure it does I'm
sure they prepared for that many people
they've had that many people before what
was the venue again I don't remember it
was scary it was old it was like in
Hollywood and it was creepy looking it
was old and tall and huge inside with
carvings of like
the Ted Talk building kind of yeah
anyway
concert's going on and I'm like uh so
I'm like [__] on no lie I had my hand
on Rosie's backfield things were two
seats away from the stairs and I was
gonna throw her in the stairs if I felt
that she'd give
I really felt weird
anyway that's just my stupid ass brain
thinking of every shitty possibility
because Final Destination Devin Sawa
[__] me up
Professor collapsed you've been happy
you had a plan yep see thank you that's
why I'm prepared anyway
shows going along shows going fine and
first and then like after one of the
songs Lil Wayne just looks at the stage
and goes y'all don't [__] with me huh
and smiled and laughed I was like what
does that mean
these model lives so everything must be
fine
sorry about half an hour between into
the show he goes all right I'm gonna
bring out some of my artists I'll be
right back
he brings out like two artists
which is odd to like have your opener
your art is like in between your set
which is a little odd but
everybody was happy everybody was stoked
then the artist came out which was like
okay you know a couple people like oh
yeah I'm gonna use this time to go to
the [__] bathroom real quick not in a
rude came out by himself
the art is yes Lil Wayne just left the
stage
so we're like okay okay
cool
it's going along
does two or three songs not everybody's
like jumping up and down because Lil
Wayne's not on the [__] stage that's
who they came to see right
second guy comes out like oh all right
we're not talking about Drake and Nicki
Minaj these are some random people
coming out well no no they're his
artists they're not random people
they're his
but most fans probably don't know them
yeah but I don't know you know anyway
either way
nobody's being rude and booing them
and uh second guy comes does two songs
third guy comes out right third guy
comes out the first two dudes people
weren't you know
they didn't really care but then we're
being rude people guys like yo get your
hat and a couple not like if Lil Wayne
was doing because obviously they're Lil
Wayne fans
so it's not like people were being rude
but they weren't like super hyped
like they were for Lil Wayne obviously
but the third guy comes down he's like a
Mexican Spanish dude and you know we're
in La there's a lot of [__] Mexican
Spanish people in the crowd and you
started wrapping in Spanish some fools
were like all right cool cool so like
people where so multiple acts come out
three acts come out mid Lil Wayne act
yeah but they only did two songs each it
wasn't too long okay I mean what it's
like five to six minutes a person not
too much so we're only like minute 10 in
okay 12 in because the second guy goes
third guy comes out third guy comes out
does one song
um
all right and this is where I'm gonna
talk to the camera you ready third guy
comes out does one song
about to do a second song and when he
does
right when he comes out
he walks out about to go to the turn to
the DJ and do the next one and he sees
Lil Wayne come out on stage
and Lil Wayne walks out and people like
oh yeah yeah like they must got a song
together
and the artist was like that he looks
confused I'm like oh damn is he bumping
the artist so he can come back on stage
and in my head I'm like I wouldn't even
feel bad that's Lil Wayne Bro get the
[__] off stage that's what I thought if
I was him like I wouldn't even feel bad
[__] you're a little Wayne let you on
the stage bro that's hard you know
that's how I was thinking like don't
even I won't even take it personally
like that's [__] Lil Wayne
he comes out
looks at the crowd looks at his artist
and starts talking to his artist don't
worry like we work too hard for this
and I thought it was a skit he's looking
at his artists
and he has the mic he looked back his
DJ's like we work too hard to try to uh
to try to uh break our backs for these
people and he points at us at the crowd
and I'm like oh this is a skit
and he goes have a good night thank you
very much we're out puts the mic down
and I'm like oh okay skip and he starts
walking off and as he's starting to hit
the stage I have a very good memory I'm
on the the right part of the stage
he starts to walk
turns around looks at somebody off stage
and goes
walks off stage and right when he hits
the side of the stage and I see him
start walking I go that wasn't a skit
he's gone
what
I I think Lil Wayne's Still awesome
I almost felt a little offended of like
what did we do just like that like what
did we do I'm part of that crowd of
people that paid for that show not even
the payments like
we weren't
like hyped enough
or do you think you should have started
two and a half hours later felt like not
being there I waited there for hour 45 I
showed up an hour late just in case he
got the we got late hour 45 later he
started I was like damn I was like I'm
tired so it's not like I wasn't hide I
was just kind of tired I've been sitting
there smoking weed I smoked all my weed
and I was like [__] before the show even
started
I'm not saying anything bad about him
like I just felt like bro what did we do
we were hyped we were waiting for you to
like we were all still all stoked
but then again maybe from his
perspective the fools in the front
aren't like we're like not so I don't
know what he was seeing so I can't say
like the Apple's a jerk I'm not saying
that yeah that's why I said Lil Wayne's
toe I felt slightly offended I'm like
bro I'm In This Crowd I didn't do
anything wrong
Rosie's this is her favorite you're her
favorite artist yeah
so this is how you're gonna do it
tonight oh
bro like rose is so excited and it just
got done
did you look at me like this is crazy
she's like are you kidding me like Rosie
that was a real she was
and I sat there for like 15 minutes in
disbelief until the lights turned on
and I was just like bro for real
I would feel so bad doing that like I
would never stop thinking about all the
people that drove out and parked and
[__] sat and waited and I'm not I
just [__] sent him home like or the
guy next to me and this girl he walked
back down and when he right it was two
seconds after Lil Wayne left and he came
back with his drinks like that what's up
what's going on
I saw him like damn that sucks he walked
into like my parents just got divorced
like the awkward like uh sit down and
I'll tell you
I've never heard of that before I don't
know I don't know and like again I'm not
saying you're bashing away but I'm
saying yo that sucked yeah that's really
professional performer you kind of owe
it to your fans and not just kind of a
good show after you kind of the dude
that ride at me oh he was not happy yeah
I mean I'm sorry try to chant he started
trying to start a chant and he was like
kind of drawing so I'm gonna go out to
the bus [__] this he said they're gonna
try to [__] skip out and he [__]
bolted like the Apple ran after the
[__] store bust Jesus Christ he was
pit and he was learning every [__]
word by word
so like a die-hard fan in two seconds
went off what the f I was like damn
fools can turn on you quick
holy [__] it was like a guy die hard to
it's like [__] [__] daddy bolt is like
they're gonna be on the butt and he ran
like Jesus imagine chasing down the bus
I saw the bus leave I walked down and
watched it [__] leave the front
around you just walk just drive right
out the side damn
as me Rosie's kept looking into like I
can't believe it
how little was Little Wayne actually
because when he went on all the smoke
I'm not sure you could I'm not sure
because I mean he he was on the stage so
and I was above him
gotcha but
like it was just sad thank you it was
just Jesus Christ anyway fast forward I
posted on on Twitter like yo I don't
know what happened but
this is what happened I tweeted it the
next morning I woke up and no jumper
posted my [__] and I got a thousand
people tag me I'm like oh cool cool they
post my tweet
you're right
then two days later I went to New York
and I was in New York and then some
people hit up Rosie that no Rosie I'm
like yo
they're talking about Thomas on the
radio in New York
either talking about Lil Wayne thing
because it started going viral like Lil
Wayne stops mid-aps you know I mean mid
concert so I'm like for real and I just
landed in New York I'm like huh what are
the odds that's crazy and then I get
tagged on like five different rap
Outlets they're using my tweet over and
over and over I wasn't being a jerk I
was being very polite
but I'm like bro I like Lil Wayne when
he Googles my name when he wants to come
with a show he's just going to see
everybody just me talking about him
leaving the show incredible real bad
it's gonna look like we don't like him
no we love your ass so hold on
then I'm on live in my and somebody I
know from back home is like bro you're
on the news like for real they put me on
the damn news in the Central Valley
talking about the Lil Wayne thing and
use my tweet
[Music]
and they didn't say Merced local they
just said YouTuber it's like bro use
that [__] to your message I'm from you
from your spot
um
so I was like damn that sucks now he's
gonna think I don't like him when he
Googles our name or something I don't
know I just thought I just thought it
was really funny the fact that like bro
the one thing people use online
talking about a negative situation one
of the top people we'd want on the show
and now it's like that's all they oh
how many songs did you do like six and
after the second every song ended thank
you
thank you
I like that yeah
thank you I was like dude she was sick
he's all he's all stoked thank you every
time real quiet thank you at the end
like Prince
I was like this is tight this is a good
show he he looked like he was having the
best time was he doing all [__] or new
[__] old [__] heavy as hell
you started off with the newest one the
DMX one that [__] was hard you hear that
one I don't I reminded him with a DMX on
it or no you ever heard the song I might
have I'm not sure it's hard you started
off with that song
he had a whole Kobe outfit on Lakers
outfit on damn I just felt like
I've never been on like dates like that
but I'm assuming like if a date's going
really good and they just get up in the
middle like I'm out like what did I do
then you start contemplating like
what did I what did I do yeah am I weird
because he's like [__] this crowd
basically I'm like
man Brothers In This Crowd we're hyped
wait I am In This Crowd the people next
to me are screaming you're lit what's
going on and then I thought you know
what there must be something going on
yeah something must be going on
Backstage about some [__] that wasn't
cracking right and they had to evacuate
him yeah something I don't know what
happened but I'm like bro what happened
anyway yeah I didn't really think that
was gonna happen and then we left the
studio and then what the two days after
we leave the studio
Lil Wayne's I see the picture a BTS
picture of Lil Wayne on set and you just
see our set next to Lil Wayne on the
side oh yeah
and what are the odds of this is that
our set our last set we just left and I
was just at your show
first jerk that's how I felt like oh
the one person we always say we'd love
to have
a look I would love it so much uh I
still love the full it's like
if you ever get him on that show my ass
like what was the LA show about bro yeah
right like because I was in that crowd
was height
nobody around me was not
soaked hopefully there's an emergency I
was worried about the floor breaking
because people were jumping up but was
it a big venue or it was a it was just
Ted Talk exactly the Ted talk just like
the crazy old building
it was big though I don't know anyway
that happened and then while I was in
New York I posted a video I was just
smoking a [__] rosin joint in New
York while we were walking around and my
mom popped up and I'm like hit this and
then she wouldn't hit it and she was
like
like you're gonna hit that [__] and she
hit it and right when she hit it
Rosie popped in camera and then my mom's
boyfriend Zeke and Rocco and it was just
like a very like crazy come together
moment all at once Quick Clip and I
posted it and then randomly I'm on I'm
in the back of an Uber I'm like people
like yo whiz posted you I'm like what
the Wiz Khalifa just posted me and my
mom getting high randomly on Twitter
just repost like retweeted like quote
tweet or whatever I'm like of all the
things I've ever done in my life for me
this is the one okay that's random
that's random did he say anything or he
just retweeted just retweet and put moms
love worms like the worms yeah okay I'm
like okay
I don't know
but that's cool it's pretty wild
I don't know did your mom know that it
had rosin in it
no I don't tell you that she'll probably
want to hit it
no but the [__] Taylor Gang post me
that day and put just put caption goat I
was like damn that's gone sick
I appreciate that thank you very much
that's really cool
yeah that was a random thing like Wiz
Khalifa posted what did they post you
and your mom performance
what ran through your mind all your top
weed moments no I thought hey Mom mural
Wiz Khalifa's Twitter right she's like
what
it's right behind me in the Uber like
look well cause you got a big ass car it
was pretty funny
um can we go back to the notes real
quick
and how long have we been here
about 2 20 I think nice real quick I
went to New York for my mom's birthday
right
what you knew her for my mom's birthday
took her out there she's never been
there she loved it she's ready to move
she loved it oh sure yeah oh I decided
I'm gonna move to New York now right now
but I'm gonna move there for like a
couple months out of the year I always
go there for like two months come back
two months come out later when we can do
it no this is this is what I'm doing not
talking about anytime soon
that'd be fun I like New York anyway we
did the all the stuff went to see the
Book of Mormon uh the Broadway play of
the South Park creators it's just
hilarious anyway we saw a book of Mormon
went to the MoMA every single oh
at the MoMA met a couple shout out to
you from Texas that follow the show
there's fans right
I'm walking out of the theater five
hours later
boom there they are again they're like
bro yeah right I'm like no [__] dude
what are the odds of this and the dude
sitting right behind me loves the
[__] show there's so many fans in New
York just it's just so sick I met like
six people at the moment oh I didn't
tell you I was at the moment and Gordon
Ramsay was right there eating food I was
like damn poor Ramsey's hard as hell
dude New York celebrities just walk they
don't they don't nobody cares they're
just existing I saw like five celebrity
fools I knew right off the bike yo sick
I was in the airport
and he kept looking at me obviously
recognized because we were from the same
area but I'm like yo I haven't seen
G-Eazy in a minute like that
[__] is tall and he was sitting
he was standing next to me I looked at
him he looked at me like so I'm like
what's up man he looked at me again I'm
like
it's airport [__] I'll see I'm not gonna
be like yo what's up bro we normally the
same [__] eight people that's why
you're right like that's how I recognize
you because you're cheesy you ready to
pick up the we do that your friends know
but I was like damn G easy you know what
I mean like that but I'm not I'm like a
huge fan to where I'm like yo bro
I [__] wouldn't like love all your song
that album like if it was I would be
like yo bro that I was sick as [__] have
a good day yeah I bounced not to bug him
but
I I felt fake going bro love your mate
yeah I don't know I haven't listened to
your new album yet so I feel kind of
like
hmm yeah so I was like you know what
leave me and then I saw Chris Ray from
SNL I was sitting next to him like oh
[__] [__] Chris red all right cool
um
and I was just walking around I just saw
a bunch of Fools and then I saw Danny
cordray from the office the one that
dated Pam started walking by me we went
to CBGB the punk stork my mom has been
talking about that place since I was a
kid and we took her there
I [__]
see these are the moments that I'm glad
that like we're finally doing good and
like we can do stuff because I was like
buy the art on the wall they have
pictures for like original pictures from
the spot signed
but their ball their two they're
expensive and I was like pick one and
she grabbed it and she didn't know how
much it was and she couldn't take it
back and we already left so she can't
[__] say no
she had no idea how much it was and I
was like buy that [__] right now and I'm
just sitting here like [__] yeah it's
like this used car like [__] yeah I'm
just excited like you you can do stuff
like um
give it like I'm so [__] happy like I
can finally do that [__] but it's a punk
store and she walked in I haven't seen
my mom that happy in a long time what
was that all right all no all the punks
all the bands used to play there they
used to be the [__] spot my mom
explained she knew all my mom was all
the [__] history of all the bands
everybody like Talking Heads used to
live right there and they got discovered
right here and they used to come over
here and so and then she talked about
the owner I'm like damn my mom's hell
into punk music
so she was hyped but uh the art on the
wall was like bands in front of the
store band playing in the store like old
1971 picture [__] fools rocking out
in the store and [__] like one's on one
Prince gotcha and I I got her one of the
of a of the band called The diplomats
but they're in front of the store when
it first opened Jim Jones the camera bro
it's crazy the Sim of this [__]
if you go there you may see a little
sticker a little sticker of me I slept
up
with all the Flyers they used to put
they encased it with glass right on the
wall like all the Flyers originally from
the from the all the bands that ever
came they just encased the whole wall in
class
like Fuller from 1976 all 71 with all
the Staples all over stuff it's like a
sick store bro you can feel it right
when you walk okay and my mom just was
too hyped dude I'm excited
um that's so cool she was just [__]
stoked
um the artwork is just a dude and a
chick who's punkers with these big ass
hair there's a band and they're standing
in front of the store but it's like
it's a photo from a photographer that
did all the pictures for their spot it's
hard man but there was one with a clash
but it wasn't in front of that stores
from a different stores it's like huh
and there's a blondie one that was sick
all of his time and all that [__] but
like
it was in front of a different Hotel it
wasn't like the same like Mom you came
to New York and bought that [__] off the
wall like that's why I wanted like oh
[__] yeah anyway we did that I was so
excited that's awesome and right we
walked outside
um I saw the fool from the office walk
by I'm like Danny cordray oh [__] I just
want to bug The Falls Police was just
walking by talking on their phone hey
what's up man yeah what
in L.A you would never see that you've
seen a couple office people on in life
right oh yeah yeah I'm getting there
getting there to one of them goes hey
high five uh-huh thanks man I've helped
me through life
um anyway New York trip was great it was
super fun uh that we had a lot of fans
and every one of them comes up bro it's
either I love this exact story time they
tell me or about the the podcast and
that's instant or they go where's Marty
and go he's home
everybody always asks like bro I am at
the grocery store people like where's
Marty I'm like
I don't know he's probably at home
but my mom at the grocery store
I am I think I'm going back to Buffalo
for like a week coming up
you ever heard dreading of human's voice
you ever heard that well now you can use
it as an example I guess I want to go
back to Buffalo for like a week
what are you going for man whatever oh
cool never mind who
oh nice
um
contemplating I haven't been back since
right before I met you so I've been back
two series and what's ironic is that
while the week that I'm Gonna Be There
is our 10-year anniversary of moving yes
that exact days nice it's weird good I
like that so I was thinking about going
to get motivational piece here to be
able to use yeah take my good visual
take cam back around the old
neighborhood and [__] it might film it
or something good you're gonna go Film
It Sick
um
oh yeah New York trip we did New York
and then we came back
and my little sister is now 18. for my
little sister Michelle my little sister
Grace she turned 18 the day I got back
and I'm like what are you gonna do I'm
gonna get a tattoo and get lottery
tickets
she went hours later and got it done she
wasn't lying
I don't remember Little Words little
words in red cursive it actually looks
pretty cool um it's really weird though
she's 18 bro oh my God I was eating tuna
sober and in purgatory called Clackamas
Portland Oregon just sitting there like
damn well this is just like two months
old
I was just eating tuna on lettuce sober
no friends
inmate a hundred percent
doing nothing watching Cruel Intentions
and speed speed one over and over
because all I had on tape on tape VHS
[__] yep
that's cool
so this is [__] fire it is really
good yeah that's bad if I can admit it
so
oh I'll do my next little topic real
quick
for everyone out there
you can just be happy for people just
you just be stoked you know people do
good things and they accomplishing [__]
be happy you know what that does makes
your life better because why would you
not be happy for someone doing something
really good right so when I say that I
mean if you make content just be happy
for people there's certain people that
make content I do not care for
whatsoever I think they're lame that
I've met personally
but when I see them like through other
people and they do good [__] I never
once not said good [__]
because you cannot like somebody and
still go damn well that's hard good
[__] job
and then walk away and that's it
even though you don't like that person
so there's not a lot of that around and
we're talking about it earlier like
there's not a lot of people like
genuinely just being like good [__]
right so I'm saying that in terms of
content creators not a lot of content
creators just yo that feels hard he's
dope support each other
I'm gonna say this
out of every content crew I've ever met
nobody's been more genuinely like
yeah you're my favorite person
than fulcrum when I met him he's like
bro me and my mom just watch your
stories you're my favorite YouTuber when
I first met him I never walked in I go
yeah yeah yeah thank you that was
awesome right and then I saw a no jumper
clip they were just like filming him
[__] around and who's the best Witcher
of all time no has double zone I'm like
hard right I just like him I think he's
a genuinely nice cool and he's [__]
funny he's just odd he's he's so himself
yeah so well I went to his show he had
his first show in L.A I went to a show
two nights ago
just to go his music show his music show
volcker makes music guys because He
makes music he's on a tour all across
the country he's about to hit New York
he's probably been in New York as this
video comes out so the reason I'm saying
that is
and make a vlog and do anything I just
went to like support this fool and be
there and make sure like
you know when that show's over you I'm
still standing next to the stage like I
didn't just like bounce get a pick and
leave my friends did things before the
internet yeah like I just wanted to be
like yo
Port right so if you're in New York get
ready because check fulcrum's Instagram
he's going to be there this week or I
hope he didn't pass yet but he said next
week anyway the reason I'm saying that
is uh I went to fulcrum show
and people were so excited like that's
it's
so awesome not everyone there was weed
people like not a huge percentage at all
like at all so I really appreciate like
yo you're bringing more fools to the
weeds views through his music yeah
because you see folks music but then you
see his Instagram then you see his like
elseful does Halloween videos and maybe
people didn't see videos before now
um I like it yeah
that's smart I just looked around like
dude none of these people are smoking
this is hard so what a lot of people
that ask me in music like what should I
do like
look at fulcrum look how he just
whatever you want built up those
following randomly nothing to do with
his music really like blew up over here
off of YouTube and now he's introducing
people to his music
ddg he has number one hit
a lot of people
a lot of people number one I can't
remember feeling well I'm speaking out
I'm [__] speaking of my ass right now
um
yeah I went to the show and the full
it's just
just too cool he's just so genuinely
nice love to hear that I [__] with him
heavily he's a very nice dude Damian's
awesome
um because you don't know like I mean he
experienced such a like super quick like
rise up in like awareness and everybody
kind of being all up in his [__] so it's
nice to hear that he's like still yeah
and I'm sure there's a lot of people
coming across and that are just like yo
I gotta take advantage of this Fool's
hype real quick
and it you know what I mean like
um I'm glad that you know that's not
taking place yeah he's doing his own
thing which is very cool to see yeah and
it's cool to see a YouTuber doing
something outside of weed like young
Mike makes hard music yeah young Mike's
music is [__] tight I actually
genuinely think it's dope go listen
and it's just cool to see that yeah hell
yeah they're out there really doing
anything because it's like you get to
know them and shut on the show yeah oh
but you're actually really talented yeah
oh you do [__]
we heard the thyroid G is the same
person evil man oh gee when I heard the
music was shut the [__] up you make this
music for all of you out there didn't
see that rology is evil main the same
[__] person
he didn't tell me I knew him for a year
oh I didn't realize that I didn't even
so conspicuous about this I just never
really connected the two oh
damn damn
shit's hard
um so yes speaking of fulcrum
you guys
I'm trying to set up for next week after
he gets back from from uh his tour you
ready for the Goat episode part two
It's Gonna be Me Marty Goblin Eric Khan
fulcrum
that's gonna be a very wild episode of
different personalities going on
I'm excited should be [__]
interesting I'm gonna bring a bag of eat
for each person just let me do the first
one yeah and on time every 20 like pull
something pull something you gotta you
gotta host it like um
look octagon or what octopus hand just
be smashing [__] to people I'm so
excited tentacles hands
so yeah we're gonna do the Go episode
part two I'm very excited about that
it's gonna be sick as hell
let's go
so Marty I have one last little topic
anything else you wanted to go into
I don't think so I'm just gearing up to
uh
put out my first ever online course and
coaching program
that
I'm hoping within the next two weeks or
so to have an actual sign up for because
it's going to be limited
I'm opening up to the podcast Community
First because it's going to be limited
because you can go and put it out on a
million different streams
but I think it's going to be called
skills that pay we're gonna get into all
the different
it's gonna be different than any other
online course out there in the wide
variety of things that we get into
that's going to take somebody from being
a beginner in something completely to
having enough wherewithal to kind of go
out and start making some money built-in
online weekly like coaching sessions
and it's going to be like uh we're gonna
I'm gonna figure it out but I've been
doing a lot of research listening to
books studying just to make sure that I
really do this deliberately and do it
right because I just have so much
information I got 15 years super high
level experience and a lot of different
things
and I just have a lot of little tips and
tricks and I just want to get just what
you need to know to make you like a
digital Swiss army knife like we say
where you have a bunch of skills that
you can go out into little different
Niche Industries and start stirring up
money whenever you want locally online
in a variety of different ways you got a
bunch of skills that pay
[Music]
so we'll see we'll keep you guys posted
on that chat but hopefully by next
episode I'm gonna have a sign up for
them where you can like claim your spot
and should if you want to be a part of
it and that first class I'm really
looking forward to because I want to
teach I want to coach and help people
and a lot of people that do book on
tapes and [__] you know I'm not saying
anything I'm saying more of you could
actually hold the person accountable
and know where they're gonna be every
week yeah if you think it's a scam it's
not you know I mean like we're not going
to put an angle that's the guy that got
me the online course that don't told me
[__] give me Google links
don't worry like that's why we always
say like I'm so happy that we're back
doing our own thing yeah you can do that
if anything it's going to be too much I
have to decide like I need to make this
concise
if anything man people are going to be
like you put this out for this much the
[__] yeah because I'm gonna make it more
way more affordable than other online
courses on par with it and building
coaching and [__] build the [__] out of
my life and bonus footage I'm gonna go
in there like this is how you bag up
[__] eighths
bonus module
okay there you go
okay I mean
like a Spencer's Gift picture book how
to sell weed oh that there you go that's
[__] cool
just picture me
find a connect maybe a grower just
pictures
I need a new plug
my guy disappeared this new fat guy has
hands of a magician and fights
what do I do now I can't even lay a hand
on him
little cartoon thing oh man
I love that that's so funny little
[__] idea that's a great idea isn't
it it's not bad you have to flip the ace
you can't smoke the aim if you flip it
for this you can smoke at least 0.6
and if it's you and your homies that's a
blunt not a backwood but a blunt
[Laughter]
who would never be able to talk about
this over there like yo guys it's been
three [__] hours there's six people
here
it's night time yeah who's your friend
oh gee he's drunk saying wetter a lot uh
can you get him like under control I'm
so glad we're back here that was the
last time Emoji was harassing you during
the ad reads oh my God no door frame huh
he was standing right there like an
idiot I touched my face with weed
about the breakout or get bumps it's
okay
better
don't worry I'm gonna work on it because
now that we're accepting weed
sponsorships and cannabis related
products now we're gonna have pre-rolls
of fire and stuff ready to go so I don't
have to itch and scratch my face and be
able to give you guys like
cool stuff to go look at give a [__]
about yeah like we love ads ad reads and
cannabis non-cannabis [__] like we've
been doing we made a big statement by
doing all them too yes we did about 50
of them and doing no weed ad reads for
two and a half years I think we did a
good job
as the people consider weed show to come
out your first two and a half years not
have one sponsorship from this year from
your own industry out of pure fear of
the platform you post on
damn we say it like that sounds way
worse than saying out of YouTube yeah on
the platform you post on damn
okay it's okay so
on that last topic
Marty's online course is coming out very
soon it's going to be cool because we're
not gonna put out something stupid yeah
of course when I say we I Marty's part
of it's Marty's
like everything we do is all like [__]
we do yeah
we did it like in the dope like I'm not
gonna I don't know it's you know what
I'm saying it's one big team yeah
one big umbrella yeah but no it'll be a
I've I've already I've done this before
and it's like I'm not rushing into this
so yeah I'm being real deliberate and
real smart about it and my attention was
just to give back through it
oh it's gonna tastes like a Kool-Aid
powder
or the roof of my mouth
yeah I can see that like a power yeah
yeah for damn sure
that [__] has two tastes oh cereal milk
all right here we go
to both not cereal or milk but just
tastes like some fires it tastes like
this powder powdered milk
it's Rat City
I forgot I turned the camera went oh
[__] we're filming
are you ready it's really good it's
really good here we go guys this is my
last topic and I'm Gonna Leave off with
this
we talked about it earlier or did we
talk about it on camera wow I love when
that happens yeah we're back exactly we
talked for an hour and a half before the
show started
when the show started
table breaks down
all right here we go
this is this last topic I talked about
earlier like yo oh my God start focusing
more on the things I'm doing it's up
with my effort my brain power my
bandwidth out toward other things that
aren't going anywhere
that only frustrate me because they're
not going anywhere when they should
um
if somebody Alec gives you an alley you
[__] dunk it
someone throws it up for you jump up and
grab that [__] please
um yeah so here we go here's my last
thing and I do not I hate talking about
negativity things
are you talking about negative stuff and
shitty things but I have to talk about
this because it's bugged me for like a
month and a half
and
here we go
so
I have
you guys know that from 2012 to 2019
2020 I worked for free I did context I
loved it Rosie knew I was gonna be broke
we were very broke he doesn't heard the
whole story I've almost had to move back
many times I couldn't afford rent it's
just too much I'm gonna make money
when I can't make money off what I do
every day
so
like I was everybody knows that people
in my hometown my family they all know
that
especially the fans I'm way closer to
the fans I feel like than I am to people
in real life which is wild to say
or I can I feel like I can be more open
does that make sense even though people
that I know personally might watch the
show
it's like a weird it's like a separation
I get knowing that I'm talking directly
to people that understand what the
you're here because you like it you're
here because you understand us that's
why I feel more comfortable when I say
in Ted Talk we're all weird and we found
it we're all weird and we found a place
to come to feel normal so I can feel
cool and normal you know what I mean
like I feel lame talking about this in
front of certain people like no I feel
cool talking about this in front of this
crowd you know what I'm saying yeah like
we're good with this crowd we're fine
so I don't know why it feels like that
anyway
like I never made anything right I was
so broke I was so I was always just
struggling
then it changed right I started doing
better and I don't know if I turned this
told the story I think I told him live
the first time I legally had five
thousand dollars in my savings account
and I didn't have to spend it on rent
was right when covet started
and then I spent it all because I know
fools needed that [__] in covid and I
went damn if I can make five bands and
spend it all on not us
I did something really good you know
like I was like I'll buy this I'll send
it I'll buy this I'll send it I was just
helping people out when that needed that
I knew personally
and I spent like almost the 5K and I
remember thinking
that's good like that's good
the first the first money I had is gone
but like for a good thing and I don't
feel stupid doing it
and then I don't know what happened the
universe was like bro that's I [__]
with that here
I don't know what happened I know I'm
saying like I did this good deed for
good things to come that's not what I'm
saying I just like I was doing it
because like I could finally help and I
could finally help with things that
needed help right now money solved the
things that you needed here boom buy
this here go get this it's covid yo you
don't have that Merced was bad there was
no food there was no nothing there was
no diapers my homie just had a baby
it was shitty it sucked it was shitty it
sucked right
so
boom month later I started like actually
making money my money where I was like
astonished and when I say astonished I
mean like
a lot of people probably don't think
it's a lot of money if I was making like
more than my double my rent I was making
double my rent and that's like
[__] I miss me I'm saving half my half
my money is going to rent half of it
it's like me Bob and I started to make
it and I started doing a little better
and a little better each month was doing
a little better and I was keeping a
notebook of every single thing I did and
I had bought stickers to put little
stickers by each [__] day so I know
it was done and all calculated I was on
my [__] because I had never made any
money and I was like don't squander it
don't let it go away like make this work
and uh it did and I started doing more
things I started focusing more on things
that I can actually make money on
starting to prevent some more and push
trees when I had that money put in the
push trees and it started working
and then we said the dopest and then you
know the podcast was started doing it
was doing so well
and it was working I never once I've
never once walked into a room go yeah
bro
look at this [__] look at this [__] like
I've never done that I just bought a
watch the first time so it's not like I
never did like did Money pictures into
my ear and posted it I have a picture of
money to my ear I put and my face was
the first legal money I ever made and
it's in my own room
and I'd say in my own room in my house
is not like my [__] screensaver and
[__] or my profile picture I'm not I I
don't like that I'm not that person
even when I made started making money
I'm I'm wearing Vans again I'm wearing
red Vans again even though my foot hurts
I shouldn't wear Vans
um like I'm not that guy to be like yo
you're a dick I've been to many places
where I wanted to buy some [__] and I'm
with certain homie that I'm gonna know
like bro that's that's a that's a weird
thing to buy from somebody that can't
buy it I feel that way like I don't want
to be like yo I'm gonna grab this even
though I should be able to do what I
want but I don't want to make that fool
feel weird or something I know people
probably been in that situation I've
probably been in that situation with
other people and didn't know because
they didn't want to make me feel weird
or or however it was I never would feel
weird I'd be like yo sick you bought
this [__] it's hard because it's that's
just me I'm glad [__] yeah good [__] you
know like I was driving the Honda when
everyone in my all three of my homies
had Lambos
and I barely got the Hunter and I was
still proud as [__] of it like I just
don't care like if I ever get that hard
if I don't bro I'm still happy making
content I'm doing my [__] I love this
so the reason I say all that stuff is I
finally started making money
I never changed I never did anything
different I I posted the stuff I was
buying because it counts as posting as
part of social media I can now write
that off on my taxes every single thing
I've ever made a video on it wasn't the
flex on you it was just like yo I bought
all this stuff thank you guys very much
I've got this stuff remember I did the
shopping spree I'll do shopping videos
all the time but like on Snapchat posts
like yo I check out these new shoes
these are sick
I also get to write that off so don't be
a hater let me get some [__]
taxes back okay
anyway people even though I'm sitting
there thanking you so much like thank
you so much you I wouldn't even be able
to buy this pair of shoes if it wasn't
for you guys so the reason I'm saying
that is like a lot of people just
started being really mean to me
like very rude like just
people that I've seen in the chat for
years just started talking [__] to me
like you're a [__] Rich [__]
you're like you're you're the Old Yeller
would have never bought a Mercedes like
bro I've talked about one in your
Mercedes since season one of story time
that's my dream car as a kid
what changes I finally accomplish what
I've been talking about for 14 years of
my life
and say one day I'll get that [__] and
now people like you you're changed like
bro I change we've all I've been rooting
for myself to try to get that now that I
get it I'm an [__]
I've never once but yo check out this
new V12 [__] you don't got this you
don't got like bro if I ever act like
that you can [__] tell me and punch
me I I don't do that like it's not me
so the reason I'm saying all of this is
because
I won't say who but somebody in my
family that I trust very much maybe it
was drinking a little bit
spilled the beans on some [__] a little
bit that I didn't know was even a thing
but let's just say this real quick I'm
not saying this to get us flagged by
YouTube but
the biggest threat to Mexican people is
Mexican people
Mexican fools hate on Mexican food so
hard
I don't know what it is
but
it's like a cultural thing I don't know
George Lopez in the stand up said it
best oh you think you're all hot and
[__] now I'm like damn bro I just got a
job he's like
oh you don't you got a job
damn [__] didn't have a scandal for
hating on another Mexican dude which is
a kind of a funny thing to put there but
he said it best in his in his first in
his first stand-up that got real big why
are you crying I think is what it was
called and uh
so I'm just saying this I don't care if
they see I hope they see and hope I
haven't done anything different I'm just
hoping to make enough money to buy
everyone a house
one day when I have this damn push trees
weed [__] going and we're worth 100
[__] 200 million dollars which will
happen
am I saying for for [__] cool thing
it's like yeah we're gonna be popping I
already know what's gonna happen I can
see it in my hand I'm visioning I'm
planning and programming into the
universe
like that's a good goal like 200 million
dollars in a year sounds crazy
absolutely it's reasonable with the Wii
company and then I can go buy everyone
in my family house
because that's a lot of money
I feel like bro this is just I this is
all I wanted to do is make sure you're
good
you're good you're good
not like yo I bought you a [__] house
remember that no I've never I've never
done that in my life the way that you've
conducted yourself understands like
you've seen it documentaries about it
you've seen it the level of selfless
giving like it makes me be like I talk
about it with my kids as an example of
like how you should be and how
very few people are and just they like
[__] makes me pissed yeah I can
imagine but I think it comes from a
place of insecurity probably in a lot of
instances it bugs me but it bothers me
because I just know how selfless you are
and how much you go out of your way for
people and me and just everybody that
I've ever seen you deal with and you do
[__] behind the scenes that I don't even
know about half the time because it's
[__] you don't even like yeah it's not
the [__] it's not like posting
what's the point of all this [__] if
we're not trying to be successful you
know what I mean like and it's happening
you gotta celebrate that because that
shows it's possible like the setting
goals I want 200 million that's coming
from the same places when I was on the
porch setting the goal to be here like
that doesn't stop I'll still I still
want to do all the same things but when
you're dealing with a mass amount of
people there's gonna be different voices
that don't know how to react to that or
don't I mean especially in your personal
life
for damn sure but that's just it just
hurts I mean it's it she shocks me yeah
because like so back to what what
Marty's saying is my cousin kind of
spilled it was like I don't know I don't
want to make you upset
but some of my fan was like
yeah I'll tell you what's been going on
so like I'm not gonna say who you know
you are but
I got a lot of people in my exercise my
family a lot of people just
I guess I'm like the topic and everybody
just thinks I'm an [__]
I don't know how that happened
I don't get it like my family like I
didn't do anything
just it really bugs me
like
what but when it comes to money though
like I've seen like certain people have
programmed to kind of be a certain way
though like despite because it's not
like I mean what could they point at
like the [__] examples would you even
have to point at or is it just the
thought of
somebody being successful that you know
I don't even know dude
but he told me that I was like bro what
the [__] did you just say
it's like and I started scanning my
brain like have I been in a [__]
hassle
no
I bought my grandma a [__] Gucci bag
for Christmas because it's my grandma
and I guess apparently it's still
[__] really talked about
yeah like I try to go flex on everybody
like
I would have gave it to her like after
then like I don't
try and do something yeah of course
to try to twist that around into some
ego [__] is yeah
it says something weird about the person
bringing it up because it's like you
can't you can't you can't turn you into
something Twisted it's too pure and too
nice like honestly I'm just glad you're
here because you see everything yeah
that makes me sad because it's like
you're such a nice giving person more
than anybody I've ever known by [__]
far
and it's like
the fact that you're experience that is
sad because you shouldn't
you shouldn't because you really go for
like super far out of your way to not
only be there for people and help people
but
like to be humble and just to
Inspire other people to push too like
[__] dude like like I told you that [__]
I don't know if I that [__] happened
like a month ago
and then it got me like dude I don't
want to [__] I'm
to tell anybody anything like that but
it's like my taxes are going to be so
[__]
but it's also like you know what
feel that way like I don't even want to
[__] talk about I bought a different
watch because I was like yo that
I bought a different watch because my
Rolex was too flashy yeah should say a
lot like oh this is like a little a
little flashy I don't know if I want to
wear this I was at the grocery store and
I had it on I went
it's a lot on a cart like what am I
doing why do I have this here I need
something to chill so like I didn't want
to tell anybody I bought this [__]
because I was like dude I feel like am I
being a [__] [__] now
no but you also don't want to be a guy
that's pretending to not be who you are
you got I just thought people like to
watch people people have to accept you
for wherever you're at in life yeah so
you're being real to yourself you're
being nice to people helping people like
but I think a lot of people that
experience success probably go through
similar [__]
but it just [__] it's just so weird
because I get it from fans fans that
I've never met
um
not people I've grown up with smoked
weed my whole life with type [__] yeah
that's horrible or not even like smoked
weed like bro we're related by blood
I'm only like said you need some weed
I'm in town yeah like I've never done
anything
that's what got me thinking like am I
insane did I forget that I did oh [__]
was that a dream or like
no
and that's what really [__] pisses me
off
and even more on [__] [__] fools
doing that [__] to Rosie too like that's
what makes me insane that's what pisses
me off because like Rosie ain't never
done nothing ever to know like I've been
there I would know if Rosie's a [__]
jerk sometimes yeah
I I I'm sometimes when I when I feel
like a dick I think about like she's the
nicest person ever you better be a
[__] [__] like I know for a
[__] fact if you're talking [__]
about her like yeah it's like you're
tripping if you're talking [__] about it
yeah it's just about families like
families a lot of times
talk [__] about each other around
depending who they're around they're
they're talking like a lot of people
talk [__] yeah I get to talk [__] but
like yo yeah either one have another
baby yeah I wanted just about to break
up like damn stop gossiping but also the
impression I have another baby
maybe you're supposed to pick up Grandma
at the airport you just [__] didn't
go because you were smoking at some
Festival uh-huh no I don't I remember
the great house on time
like I didn't do nothing to you
[__] it's not I don't know I
just think it's really weird I think
it's really weird and [__] lame and
[__] dumb yeah I wish you didn't have
to go through that because that's stupid
but now I told John last night I was
telling John about this last night
because
John Hash House is finally gonna come on
the show soon because he's on his up and
up [__] but John has been doing very
well for a very long time
and I asked him kind of about the
situation he goes of course you know
wait wait if you know 90 people you're
about 40.
so they're gonna never talk to you again
because they don't feel comfortable
because you make so much [__] money
now
I just want to smoke bowls with you when
I see you
yeah so sorry but you're also kind of
paying the price for a lot of people
that have come before you that have
turned into [__] especially and I
guess
like online
because you gotta I mean
you get to see who you really are when
you become successful like that and a
lot of people that reveals I mean like
maybe not
the best person but with you I mean it's
just so it's weird
I told you before we started remember
when you first pitched me the show y'all
can we do a 90-10 deal remember that
[__] that's the first thing you ever
pitched me I went okay yeah and I went
home I told Rosie she's like what the
[__] I go that's low
that's low yeah and then you came back
like it's got to be a little and then
we're like let's do this way different
and then now we do what we do now yeah
like yeah of course
and it's like wait
and you said and I told you I was like
I'm not trying to get rich for myself
yeah
because you told the one thing you told
me is like
damn that's insane that's that's that'd
be astronomical you said
I gotta can we structure this difference
like I I can't
you said you know I remember word for
you said
I can't be working for nothing again
while everyone buys new uh rolls trucks
it's like I've seen it
watch these fools just go buy them brand
new 500 000 cars paying me minimum wage
just like I gotta make sure I have foot
in it yeah I was like bro
do whatever the [__] you want write the
contract I'll split the ship like let's
just do this here whatever you want to
do
because like I told you like I'm trying
to read for myself what would happen
that would be the worst thing ever oh
I've been there that's [__] lame yeah
like this is like a [__] whole
partnership exactly so it's like
yeah that sounds like the dumbest [__]
I've ever heard like no yeah well that's
I mean that's that's why when I say
people have seen that before like I mean
that's most people don't move like that
or have that foresight to really value
your team and to Value people's time
like not just get what you can out of
them yeah exactly like what how many
times have I told you I got this design
but like
I'm gonna pay more this is ridiculous oh
you gotta hold somebody bro how much you
want
I'll pay more yeah I'll give you more
there's no debate there's it's too low
that's there's literally no debate
across the board about this no there's
not and if you can give me an example of
me being a jerk I would love to [__]
see this it's not gonna happen it's not
gonna [__] happen yeah so it's the
morals of that is like
damn yeah so now now that I'm now I
talked to John last night and I was like
you know what
we'll do whatever I want
I'm gonna do whatever I want you know
that as I was leaving I was listening to
this song by the rapper that we realized
lived between us and went oh I probably
shouldn't say the lyric and know exactly
who the [__] lyric is uh the gist of
it
was you can't take it with you have some
fun um
John just said I was like I'm almost
like I don't want to spy stuff I don't
want I don't need stuff I'll need this
the only stuff I've ever post is like oh
that's tax purposes yeah like most of
the stuff I've ever bought at these
stores is for other people every time
every time you post up the house these
are big [__] stamps of you guys know
what the [__] we went through to get
this that
this is the long road it's a 10-year
[__] that's a stamp for the whole
Community to let everybody know it's
possible the [__] you don't understand
if you're sitting around butt hurt about
this [__] and I'm just sitting there
just in my house I'm never like
you're putting points up on the board
that's what you're supposed to do this
is a really good angle this is what
we're supposed to do this is the point
like we're all we're not doing this [__]
to stay the same no
I was fine with that for a long time and
then I thought about like year seven I'm
like do roads you can't just sit here in
this forever yeah well I just stress
every month hoping to make red it's got
to be for a huge big it's got a beef you
do this type of [__] you're doing it for
a day where you can be financially free
you're not doing this [__] to be halfway
your whole life and safe
that's not the point when you go after
[__] like this like that's not what we
set out for
so when like that's what in the sea
we're just so young and the [__] is
happening and it's like here it's weird
like a certain percentage of people
aren't going to know how to process that
off top but
yeah
it's just a
odd thing to think about
you know when you like when you run into
a dude like death will [__] man as [__]
I want a [__] ass fool I could even go
to sleep how could you sleep with you
like how do you go to sleep
that's how I feel about when people are
happy for other people like how the [__]
do you function
you see someone like John that fool just
[__] graduated and bought a new car
like oh [__] yeah like you couldn't
believe how happy that fool is like you
[__] yeah good [__] my whole Tick Tock
is full of positivity my Twitter's
different I see something terrible
things
oh my God stop
crazy Clips just keeps popping up it's
called crazy Clips it just never stops
but on my Tick Tock I only like
positivity and funny ass things because
it's like bro that's all I want to see
so I can't think of another I can't even
wire my brain in life
the chestful yeah I mean like how the
[__] do you do that [__] this is just I
think it's crazy it's a challenge that
you got it's
something you got to get past in his
life that's how I think about certain
things like this is a unique challenge
you're posed with a lot of people don't
have happened in life and [__] and it's
like one day you'll look back and be
like I remember when I was young and I
first started really getting after it
and [__] like that and
remember how you handled it you don't
let people that aren't on that same
frequency sway you when you know in your
heart that you're being true to yourself
and true to you know not having the ego
just staying true the same person you
were what I mentioned the [__] Honda
like in prior to even having money when
you didn't have it money like just all
the time and energy and effort you put
into just people and trying to all your
friends that are living outside going
through some [__] all this [__] with
your family and all these people that's
like
like your energy force and your life how
dare these mothers like how dare you
that looks like and then it's more it's
like not it's not just because I've I
mean I feel for some homies I gotta be
honest I do I feel some certain people
I'm like damn
let you be a hyped oh damn oh my God
it's like a very lackluster like yeah
yeah
I only told you because I I'm excited to
tell you I know right my uncle John was
the best that [__] was texting
me before I even hit him up to be like
yeah gosh shut the [__] up
[__] and uh
and um
yeah I just don't get it I don't get it
I don't I don't understand that but also
it's got me thinking like
maybe it's time you don't have to
understand that [__] yeah and just do
your [__] because I gotta be honest
I I've I've felt weird and like kind of
like an [__] but why should I because
this is why I bought this watch I love
it it's too flashy the Rolex I bought
this one sounds like an [__] move in
my head like so you bought another watch
because it wasn't too flashy but yeah
once for special occasions yeah because
I feel like I can't even be at the
[__] gas station like where's my gun
all right of course yeah I shouldn't be
doing this yeah like I'll shoot you I'll
shoot you like I shouldn't be feeling
like that at all but with that Rolex I'm
like yo that shit's [__] yeah a poo
[__] yeah Aladdin diamond yeah but it's
okay there's plenty of people with two
watches no the reason I'm saying it
because I was like oh I I didn't I don't
know about watches I saw this watch I'm
like oh AP yeah so I've heard of that
before that's really my good place and
John has one but I never cared about
watches and then he showed me and go
your watch has moving parts
yo bro the whole thing see through it
so sick what the back side of it you can
see the inner workings of the watch
that's the funnest [__] I've ever seen
in my life
who cares what the like bro the bag you
can see it like the Space Jam like
[__] Bugs Bunny is on the face
yeah same same idea it's like bro this
is insane right like I don't care how
much it cost that shit's hard so John
showed me I'm like wow APS are so nice
see this is I didn't want to talk about
this stuff ever because it's like I feel
like I'm being an [__] but you know
I'm like
it interests me and then people start to
say you're a piece of [__] you old
Thomas wouldn't buy a [__] eight
thousand or a hundred thousand watt
whatever I'm like
you weren't complaining when I had 70
pounds of [__] weed in my apartment
at 2500 a piece almost 200 bands
was I being an [__] then yeah there
was way more money in my house back then
than there was when I bought a simple
watch so am I an [__] and I'm [__]
investing something so I can sell it in
case I get in a pinch I can sell this
[__] and be okay
like if I go to the bank it's just
depreciating and inflation yeah it's
like at least I get the watch that's how
I started thinking about you know what
it's an investment it's cool
but then I'm like am I a [__] [__]
like no I'm not an [__] if I was a
rapper you guys would be like yes what
rappers do yeah just because like I
didn't I I didn't know I like watches
now I do yeah I realize I really like
the holy [__]
so I'm getting rid of this yeah you
don't still live in a shitty house
either yeah I like it I didn't realize
that I liked it
that's okay it's okay you don't never
feel guilty for being successful right
so that's why I've been feeling like
damn you know I'm sorry [__] I don't
even want to talk about this [__] no
more like I just talked to guys I
thought it was so [__] cool and
interesting yeah that's all I just
thought it was really cool like holy
[__] guys like I found out about tariffs
yo what you guys don't watch because you
can see through some of these
[__] matches but yeah dude
yeah oh well I I don't know now I know
like wow that's so cool
but that's how I've been feeling so when
they told my my certain family member
told me that I'm like
it's about a watch is that why I was
like is that why let's put a watch
damn man [__] like I didn't like
I haven't been to Mercedes I bought a
car they've watched in the house or
anything I've been home
so it's not like I walked in like yeah
not Merced like I would never act like
that in my life I would probably take
this [__] before I walked in one
yeah just so I didn't make fools feel
weird about [__] yeah I gotta be honest
but now I'm not even I don't even give a
[__] now now I'm like you know what
that's how you feel when I'm being super
[__] cool
and normal I'm just gonna not because
like I said if there's been times where
I'm like I don't want to buy that [__]
right now I'll buy another time I don't
want to make this full feel weird
like you know what I I really I don't
care if you're my friend you're my
friend yeah I bought you shell all the
time
all the time so don't feel weird like
you know if I buy myself some [__] like
yeah
so it's like
it's a very weird thing that I'm in
right now I never thought I had to
experience that [__] and it's a very
weird situation of life that I'm in that
I never thought I'd be in
also it's got me thinking
just do do what I want then yeah because
I wanted to sell this the other day
because I now I know about watches there
is a they're called skeletons they're
called AP skeletons and they're
completely see through the whole entire
way I found one oh you can see the gears
and [__] oh it's a whole thing is
see-through Marty reminds me of hook
yeah yeah exactly
do you see what the [__] I'm saying now
it's just so cool like wow look at all
that [__] moving in I wish I could soon
and just see it all working it's just
fun so I felt like a dick like duh I'm
not gonna get a watch and sell it and go
get a different watch like that's a dick
move like wow I like that I want to get
that one why can't I
but then I'm like dude now like if I get
that one are they gonna be like oh this
Fool's [__] feels really just like
going hard flexing on us now like I'm so
I didn't never I've never once been like
what's this [__]
so sorry I keep saying it but I just
keep thinking like where have I done it
I have I it's just the fact that you've
done it I mean it's like reading a text
message you put your own inflection on
it depending on how you read it people
see you out there doing that and you're
assuming you're [__] a really good
[__] one because that's the way they
perceive I mean it's a great way of
putting it huh so how you take it I mean
I always say thank you and you got 98 of
all these people that have been watching
you for the past [__] how many years
like oh my God he [__] did it yeah
also dude I've got I do the I read the
comments too I go Rocco does the
comments I still hit comments when I
walk I like get into into the chat or I
get into the comments I notice Rocco
hasn't hit a cup I'll [__] knock them
out or if I see people that Rocco
already responded to you I really love
the comment I'll go ahead and reiterate
so you're gonna see two comments the
second one's like me like bro yeah [__]
yeah and by the way yeah what you're
talking about because it's like
yeah because Rocco doesn't helps me in
the comments in a thousand but I still
do like at least
yeah oh yeah all the other channels for
sure
but it's like
I I don't I don't know what I'm saying
I'm just
I don't know I'm just there in that
weird situation of life I never thought
I'd be in
but I promise like I'm just trying to
stay true to yourself follow your
intuition I'm just trying to smoke some
bowls to hang out with you just like we
used to
for real you want to get in the car it's
really fun
it's fun oh if you don't want like
that's cool too I'm not trying to flex
on you um
the [__]
[__] it's super sick in there you want
to check it out when I was telling when
I was interviewing the people
out of their positions I was telling
them like guys I've worked with dozens
I've worked with so many like
celebrities and like rich people and
[__] like there is no one better to work
for there's only better nice thank you
Marty there's no one better like thank
you he is as pure and cool as he seems
like when I'm riding with Ariana I tell
her like
key core [__] because she I mean
it's easier for a kid to relate to
somebody besides their parent
oh no no if Ariel Ariana knows she has
to know that she has some wild dope
parents she has yeah she gets it does
she has to know like April's [__]
cool yeah she has to know that and maybe
she'd know too much but of watching one
episode and then going like oh that's
I mean she you don't act different right
kids I've seen you no I feel like we're
on the same thing so it's like dude
I think they know like
it's the same like I don't know what I'm
trying to say I'm getting lost over here
high as [__] ranting but
she appreciates she's like no but she
realizes and like just has not seen all
these different instances are like bro
is like her words bro is like Jesus
[Laughter]
just about all they're giving you do oh
me behind the scenes yeah I thought you
were just saying about you like bro it's
like Jesus no no like I was telling her
about some [__] I don't even remember
like it's just it's crazy to watch I've
I've never I've been around some of the
[__] richest dudes you know oh yeah
I've never seen we know or even
experience that level of like
just
gratitude like and just I don't know
it's hard to well look at dude it's like
this
when I was doing moving and [__] I would
try to crush it no matter what so the
person's like yo that was probably the
that was the easiest and Dopey [__] ever
if someone can reciprocate that in a way
like yo when we work together we do this
like yo let's do some [__] then it works
and then because we we where we know
each other at the beginning but we
became homies over the course of like
one month and then it just become like
oh yeah Marty where is it it's like a
synonymous like yo we're chilling right
yeah and like
I don't know I feel like
it's gonna be the same dude what am I
saying again I am so awesome on what I'm
trying to say we're talking about Ariana
[__] up but um yeah why why not
if I can [__] do some [__] that'd be
sick as [__] yeah I'm supposed to what
the [__] are we living for doing this
yeah what's the whole point well the way
I see Shaq doing [__] oh bro I can't
[__] wait I saw Shaq someone was
recording him at his table was like I
saw I saw one of my companies
he says [__] basketball shorts at
home is like I saw one of my companies
and he has a check for like a couple of
his family members and he's losing his
brothers right here
he goes through he's like
those Rose trucks let's go get one it's
like even one we'll just go get it now
I'm like so you gave him at least 500
pounds I [__] love shack I [__]
love Shaq so much like bro
you know why because it's not affecting
his whole [__] like I can't pay my
rent yeah I can't [__] go somewhere
if I need to go somewhere if my kids if
I can break his arm I can take him other
than that I'm like oh my God I can help
I can do and not even help it's like bro
what family made me like you don't don't
even trip bro I'm not doing it out of
being a [__] not trying to hold over
your head it's like yo here's a Jeep
[__] happy graduation like why
can't I do that [__] yeah
that's so [__] cool yeah when I see
Shaq do that [__] I'm like [__] that's
where I wanna [__] before Rosie and I
ever made money I told her like we can
start a foundation so we can tax do a
tax [__] because Bill Gates gives a
bunch of money for taxes every year
right to a charity I'm like
I can just give money away as taxes
are you [__] kidding me I told Rosie
the second I'm rich enough to go do him
I want to walk around
and whoever's polite just hand them a
stack not film it just walk around hey
what's up man like someone open the door
hey thanks so much bro no problem hey
here because I told you a story I might
be in the grocery store counting of
groceries like that's four
I'm handling my mom's doing it I don't
know how much money she got I'm just
counting up the bill like Mom you know
it's like 106. I'm just like yeah okay
we're good and then I always think like
someday someone's gonna walk by and like
hey
here's ten thousand dollars
have a good day I always imagine like I
someone's gotta do it one day like and I
always say like money's gonna fall from
the sky and a bail for my grandma's
house and it's gonna plop down it's
gonna be a bunch of money or weed or
something it was money as a kid then we
got older I'm like a bunch of weed and
uh
I always thought that like how cool
would it be like yo how many times you'd
be in the grocery store counting up like
it's the seventh I'm already [__] yeah
[__] [__] like I've been there so many
times man and there's so many times
people walk by and I'm like
it's so crazy what like 50 bucks will
change and help me so much right now
this is nuts and I think about that [__]
all the time like how cool would it be
like saying oh this lady her little son
he looks cool yeah five bands don't say
[__] just just go just go like what like
just [__] take it you have a great
like use that [__] you know what I'm
saying like how [__] awesome would it
be I was in college struggling my ass
off for a minute and then the Wii picked
back up and I lost my connect and it was
like I was good but there was a point
I'm like [__] Where'd I get I'm
I need to sell weed [__] and how cool
would it be like yo you're in school
here don't [__] Bro God bro how fun and
just walk away
this person will never think never not
think of it again like dude that gives
me Faith and [__] exactly people are
nice
I swear I swear it will like when I put
those keys back on that motherfucker's
motorcycle when he dropped him right by
the new motorcycle but I wrote the
stupid letter stupid note for Chappelle
Show I just had to be funny
[Music]
so no matter what that person out there
one day was gonna be like that was me
and I'll get it back in eight years from
now or something I don't know I feel
like if you can do some [__] do some
[__] like this is cool like John never
talked about it but that [__] is
the hardest at that [__] I didn't even
know I know John for like seven years
and he like we brought it up last year
I'm like bro what he's like I do it
every year like what
he's like every year this [__]
goes into Target every year around
Christmas to buy [__] and he's like
whoever's super nice or polite I'll just
fill up their car with anything you want
buy it hmm it's like ever I see people
with kid like I'll just fill up the car
and buy it I pick a family every [__]
year that's awesome and he's like and
then I [__] do the fridge and I do
their Thanksgiving
I'm like what can I do over here
you're the [__] man you never even
once told me that [__] that is the
dopest thing I could ever think of but
I'm always so like John's so outgoing to
talkative to people he is the ultimate
best yeah and I'm the opposite I'm like
what if that feels hella rude to me I'm
gonna be pissed and just gonna ruin my
damn I'll punch him in the [__] head
you know what I mean like I don't want
people to be I'm always so like as a kid
like everyone was so [__] mean to me
I think it's like in my head
and someone's Supply I'm like hey what's
up man I think that's why I wanted to
meet and greets people like how do you
talk you're so free I'm so anti-social
like because everyone here is gonna be
nice too yeah
everyone here is a fan like there's no
like in like
so in the constant I'm like oh what if
the full next to me is drunk he's like a
dick or something to punch him in the
face I just don't want to hit somebody
like why is everybody in the [__]
face
it's my ultimate goal so I just want to
hit somebody because what if they pull
out a knife I'm gonna let him stab you
he wants to get close and I'll [__]
bite their neck off like I have tactics
for all this I'll let you get one
[__] in my hip and I'm gonna
kill you like I'm gonna get you close
because once you get close enough like I
don't care if you can fight I'm gonna
[__] you man I'm strong as [__] a
good wrestler you're done bro like I
don't care unless you're in my unless
you're a gray wrestler
you're pretty you're I think you're
gonna go down wrestlers got the upper
hand of course it was a lineman hmm
pretty much gotcha I just sink my teeth
into your neck [__] kill you
it went into me it's like Jesus
you're so nice man I've seen it a
[__] bunch of [__]
there you go oh nobody to not yell at
there's no there's no no other Studio
here sick I can yell bite your neck off
[__] yeah
right I did two for a minute
yo I love this I can come back and
scream whatever I say
because guys at the studio in the other
part of the studio is like 30 people
working like their normal lives like
doing computers and like doing edits and
you just and they always like oh there's
they're filming like it's boxed every
time they come in [__] [__] like it's
never been like this like
we barely spoke today
so I'm glad that I can scream bite your
[__] neck off and I'll kill you if I
get close enough to you I love the doing
the show I haven't felt this in a
[__] minute
laughs
transition he's like Jesus to biting
someone's throat out my [__] love
yeah people will pay off our layaway one
time I [__] Kmart or some [__] they
just picked a random one yeah bomb my
grandma Dolores used to do that [__]
that's [__] cool bro
cool always remember that
see you always remember that how long
ago was that probably five eight years
ago yeah exactly you always remember
like dude somebody just my grandma
Dolores used to always tell me like
always pay for the tall person behind
you
yeah it's pretty cool she always like
says some sick [__]
but yeah pay for the toll person behind
you because it makes their day or
something like that even when you think
like that and act like that before
you're you're even really on hold like
that the Universe likes that [__] you
know be a good one I don't go I don't
eat fast food but I'm gonna start paying
for the person behind me
that's cool
actually that's hard
yeah it's cool to get creative that's
being yeah that's sick now I'm thinking
of all types of [__] like I don't even
talk though but I guess I can go get
some rice and beans in a bowl
because I can't eat the [__] stupid
tortilla because it has gluten in it
yeah like you're saying everybody in
your childhood was like a dick so over
time that makes you be skeptimistic
pessimistic of everybody but I mean
imagine if that was the opposite cool
little awesome little bombs John does
that it helps a little bit explain
John's here he's gonna break the guys
with every single one person it's a
higher room yeah he's perfect so I don't
I don't remember John like oh I don't
have to worry about you if someone's
dumb he's gonna call him a dumb [__] for
40 minutes
I don't have to do this uh yeah I wrote
the job
I guess you can talk yeah I can say I I
was behind John in his Lambo I can talk
about that
illegal we're legal no
it's the most obnoxious thing I've ever
heard it sounds like straight machine
gun
let's Screech screaming almost so loud
you can't take it like from because
you've been inside it before I've never
been I've never been behind it I've
never experienced the outside it is like
machine gun fire
fireworks m80s [__] metal slamming on
[__] concrete all at once grabbing
the engine what are you down [__]
I have a video of it
yeah he was revving at the light when
I'm going to a [__] Bakery
my bro
that's the most obnoxious [__]
ain't it you know what I said and I was
like nah that's a dick move you know
what I said I'm gonna buy one dude I
fell in love with it really I want one
so far he's out of her [__] years
I've never once been like I would love
that and he drove I was driving my like
I would love that holy [__] not the
loudest I would never want my car that
loud ever just like that is this [__]
work of art like that's every little
kid's dream like limbo exactly like that
sounds fun as [__] I'm not gonna go buy
one that's I don't think I could buy one
that's something very expensive all
right I'm saying like that would be sick
gold to have like yeah remember I used
to have that on the screen then he
[__] caught it it's like a
motivational thing once again it's like
oh I'm [__] positive like you happy
that's a sure we've been pushing this
whole time yeah right see but then again
like now I'm sitting here talking about
expensive as cars like am I [__] just
being a bougie [__] talking about I
just happen to like that car you know
what else cars sick the Kia Stinger so
don't think I'm a [__] [__] the
key is Dinger is one of the hardest cars
out right now I know a lot of you like
shut the [__] up like have you seen the
Kia Stinger no it is so [__] sick
Marty okay it looks like the Mercedes GT
this bomb as [__] and it's a [__] Kia
I don't know what they're doing out
there who just the foolsom Fast and
Furious like bro hire us as your [__]
team and we'll make your car Jeep did
the trackhawk or whatever and now it's
all like hard regular Brands trying to
do like the trackhawks [__] [__] dude
it's not all about like oh that's the
most expensive bike you know Lambos are
just on yeah
so we're the new Corvettes shout out to
Eric Khan I saw him [__]
a new [__] Corvette online shout out
to that fool like
that's yeah a very positive reason [__]
this is not as easy
this wasn't some get rich quick scheme
it's like yo you're crushing it I can't
believe you should [__] worked out
this is so cool
why isn't it cool it is yeah and it's
okay to like [__] and it's okay to be
like yo good good job it's okay to enjoy
things and it's okay to [__] pet
people on the back and it's great to be
giving and to trust people or try to
help them all that's okay it's fine
motivational comedy podcast also don't
be a [__] [__]
I literally in my [__] notes put last
note talk about my family being dicks
no I says talk about my family Pete
dicks not like share my feelings don't
forget to share your feelings on the
stuff you found out like talk about all
caps talk about my family being dicks
no
I'm
I'm so excited I have poker first I'm so
happy to be back we're definitely over
three hours but I'm like happy about it
I don't give a [__]
yeah we're off in 3 30 turns yeah let's
go
[Music]
let's go folks it feels good
let's go
that was a mix
this little [__] butt mashed on me
right now that was [__] crazy
that was insane
all right hold on yeah it feels like we
haven't had a [__] episode in months
we have it
[Music]
Jesus Christ
oh yeah you can get this at the dope as
usualpodcast.com
sorry coming soon
Marty has a new size building it looks
[__] cool as [__] it looks like a
highlight reel of everything we've ever
done this is so [__] cool
we just make videos and leave I don't
ever like we'll go back and look at
everything and like we really do
I remember what I was doing that week
when I filmed it I posted it what I was
doing when I was texting I've been doing
the chat I mean all that [__]
each one of these are a cool chapter of
life
all right damn I'm so excited to be back
guys real quick
while we're here I'm gonna do a little
scary talking up close
do a small [__] favor
go hit that [__] like button
[__] it looks like a thumbs up
like on Facebook
but it's underneath on the video of
YouTube
as mister
that was creepy as [__] actually oh you
weird [__] doing this canal clicking
[__] on Tick Tock and [__] please stop
he's popping up with my [__] creepy
ass feet
I don't know why all I like is funny
dogs and positivity and fun [__] and
they keep showing me these girls
sometimes it's Vanessa x16 today we're
going to be looking my [__] Nails
it's [__] creepy [__] I've ever seen in
my life I'd rather watch [__] Silence
of the Lambs over and over again my body
rejects that yeah I don't like it it
feels like someone's in my house what
the [__] is behind me I like it I'm so
happy to be back here wow
good [__] I'm gonna pack one more Bowl
Marty let's go
anything else you want to talk about
oh real quick go follow that Clips
Channel
yeah go follow the clips here watch all
the [__] Clips leave a comment and
[__] please because that [__] will help
we have to get 4 000 hours back with
little Clips with no stories because we
didn't tell any stories when we went to
the other Studios All Guest stuff
and that Clips channel was one of the
best [__] it was so fun it was so
[__] fun they demonetized it so we're
trying to just get the monetization back
maybe we'll go a little hard after that
we'll see we're also kind of just
accepting that YouTube monetization
might not be for us yeah especially the
monetization oh [__] it's the when
you're monetized they push your [__]
because they want more views so they get
paid too yeah that's what I care about I
care that they care about it yes I don't
care about the monetization was never
huge on there yeah it's the views that
pushed back into these episodes that
made people want to watch the show yeah
and that's what's more thing all it's
always about we talk about the Ted Talk
building an online authentic following
is the ultimate thing because it will
eventually lead to something tangible um
like live shows let me go sell out
hella shows
so hey guys that's what we've been doing
thank you for being here it's been a
long time since it's been a win over
three hours it's been a long I don't
think we've ever done a solo episode
this long
yeah it was only right
never thought about that
usually we're just catching up but it's
about about [__] six bucks
weird well we're back
fully [__] back go to part two we got
the hash house up covered
yep yo you guys real quick before we
leave
we had some of the biggest artists in
the world on our show in the past couple
months right
you guys know that you've been watching
nle was super nice super cool and hella
hell insightful I didn't think it was
gonna be that that dope so
um
we had some of the biggest artists in
the world
and you know what's crazy
it's not a numbers theme but if you look
at the numbers
the people we associate with the people
you guys like people that do content are
always going to bring in more fans
is that insane yeah
like it's insane like they're the power
of authentic content creators is I've
met so many people out there folk he's
like bro he's a watcher [__] like before
I even started making videos like sick
days
why can't you be that why can't you be
the next that like for real all the
people out there I told Rocco Rocco
you're gonna listen to this right now I
told you guys in the [__] text the
other day
I think Rocco needs to be down here he
signed up for school in Fresno of course
which is cool do your thing stay stay
and go to school if that's what you want
to do
I told him why can't you be the
generation of your why can't you be the
me of your generation just not the weed
version yeah that feels hilarious
streams knows all that [__] like bro why
could I'm not saying like go get popular
I'm saying Rocco wants to make clothes
he has a [__] amazing ass line an
idea I'm like bro that's a [__] great
idea
why can't you be that put yourself out
there you got a great personality yeah
but like this is my little brother I'm
not saying because he's my little
brother I'm saying because I've watched
my little bro like that I would watch
this [__] weird-ass kid weird as [__]
like I was supposed to Goofy and [__] I
gotta watch that
and it's like do that if I think that
other people are [__] weird and think
that too they're like I like weird [__]
too
all right and then they're like wait
a year later like you're the guy the
Burberry ad like yeah well probably six
[__] one skinny look like [__]
Burberry like there's so many options
after that yeah totally I just feel like
he's in that sweet little window of life
where bro just
pay for all
but I'm not saying that to like
encourage your ass while you're doing
comments and [__] I'm saying that like
why can't you at home whoever's watching
be that
can be done it can be done it look at
look at all the examples of people we've
had on this show
that aren't just movie stars or rappers
or comedians all the content creators
look at all of them all of them have
their own following they have their own
[__] going on
and this is when we're all taboo and
we're all like not even looked at yet
and we're all being shunned
what happens when you're following is
like two years in and like YouTube's
like yo 420 section introduced
monetization fully ready to go
why can't you be there and I'm not
saying the wheat [__] what if you just
like content what do you like car
content what do you want to do a
motivational [__] class and you show
people [__] skills they pay like
Marty why can't you do something that
you can be super [__] proud of and oh
my God a [__] ball in that holy [__]
like that's a cool feeling even if it
never happened you still like yo I get
to do what I want this is [__] cool
like I said I don't care if I've ever
made money I would still be making
content that shit's fun I would had to
get a job yeah so we're not broke all
the time but I still be making contacts
so fun it's
I don't know like it's weird that this
is content because it's just us talking
yeah why can't you be out there doing it
I met uh at Fulton show a new name Pizza
Brian he's a YouTuber oh you've seen him
before okay see I saw a clip of him once
I'm like oh he's like my family member
or something and um
this cameraman I met them they're like
bro we watch [__] what the [__] we're so
stoked
good and he explained he's like we made
one video
um he's like we popped off 1.8 million
views giving strangers blinkers I'm like
bro that's such a motivational [__]
video like
one thing hit
possible like it's all it doesn't take
just that but like listen to his story
listen to mine like I was getting 200
like always getting no [__] followers
and like one day like somebody a huge
space all my weird ass picture and post
like look at this weird ass account this
was crazy and then boom that's all it
takes like a couple people to look
notice yeah
exactly dude like
so super possible so why can't you just
do it that's what I'm saying every
artist you're like man I had to show
there's eight people in the crowd you
always see that 2005 2010 they're in a
stadium like bro why can't that be you
and I'm not saying go be an artist you
need to be faint why can't that be yo I
had one customer on my landscaping
business I got [__] six employees I
got 40 [__] five accounts like why
can't that be you you don't have to be
famous why can't you be a sick ass
landscaper just crushing us you want to
do yeah and I think that's what people
need to figure out like why can't you
have a cleaning service
that you're the best cleaning service
out there my whole family is truck
drivers and movie services
why can't you and they all try to be the
best one why can't you just like that's
not just because like you know well I'm
never gonna buy a Lambo off that
who cares [__]
if it happens it happens that'd be sick
but if it doesn't be happy because
you're crushing it I was talking my new
poor guy I was I was like thinking this
[__] like this [__] is an expert
just the way he's breaking down the pool
to me and he's got a bunch of houses he
lives in the neighborhood and [__] I'm
like I don't even know what you're
saying trust that it's perfect thank you
be the best at your [__] job like why
not even if you're out there right now
we're in McDonald's be the best
[__] on the meats
all right I I quit I quit that you guys
know that story I couldn't take it
be the best I was trying my ass off when
I did it and I made sure my [__] was
clean so just be the best at what you
can do if you're at school I mean I'm
I'm not gonna say anything I was
terrible at school I didn't try at all
let's not bring up school actually
that's dumb of me if you're at work be
the best where it's cool to Cross School
though it is oh [__] yeah but I'm not
saying like go out there [__] take
extra classes because I'm just lying to
you at this point I don't know what that
does to you but for work if you keep
working your ass off you keep moving up
and if you're not go do something that
does
I worked at the U-Haul I worked
everywhere
see I mean Marty used to [__] be in a
basement you saw the picture [__] was
disgusting also go follow Marty's
YouTube page YouTube channel Marty did
like a story time version but with sick
[__] overlays of real things from the
places I wish I had pictures of the
things that I did
I just described them but like you have
real pictures go watch that [__] what's
it called that picture how I get the
coolest jobs in the world how do I get
the coolest jobs in the world on Marty
made it yeah Marty made it on YouTube go
follow this channel how many hours you
weigh from getting monetized
it's like uh still a ways away
all right it's a sick ass video I
watched the whole thing in my I remember
I chose a mortgage clip and I watched
the whole [__] thing yeah yeah that
[__] was tight as hell go watch it dude
Marty made it that is his YouTube
channel and his Instagram we're focused
on us right now we're focused on doing
our own thing making you whatever you're
doing the biggest thing possible the
biggest things about possible whatever
I'm doing trying to do
the most this was running marathons out
here
all right side missions it's just hard
that's just cool as hell so there's
there's just things I've run oh do you
remember my first [__] 5K next let's
win this so it's like we're doing [__] I
don't know the [__] trying to badass
new treadmill but use that [__] almost
every day just spawned as hell yeah I
was in Utah yesterday in the mountains
just walking uphill on my screen she was
sick
um just like say I'm dragging this out
but thank you guys for being here we're
[__] back home I'm very excited
this is cool
most weird ever damned around the show
that show was I think so I don't know it
felt like that
oh I feel like those joints burn very
fast
I don't know we'll see guys thank you so
much for being here Marty thank you guys
feel so good to be back feels like a
homecoming and [__]
really feel good about this [__] so
we're just going to keep this [__]
pushing glad we got the chance to just
kind of kick back and talk about all
this [__]
yeah it's been a while and then we play
Stained
song it's been a while and we Fade to
Black
I'm getting ready all right guys thank
you so much for being here if you're
still here here's a [__] champion
thank you so much for sitting for us for
half your shift at work
thanks and if you're it's a third of
your shifts you work 12 hour shifts
you're a [__] baller Crush that [__]
um also you're watching chat at work I
mean
and on the audio side all the audio is
coming back soon I know a lot of people
listen at work we had a little hiccup
switching the platform on the models
back over but we're getting it figured
out
it's gonna be sick all right we're
trying to pump up everything we're doing
the most we're hiring a team remember
when it was like our first season we
were just going hard uh first and second
season I should say
basically until we left this building
remember how we were going really really
hard
that's what we're gonna do again with a
team
and that's going to be [__] awesome
thank you guys so much for being here if
you can it's not monetizing drop a like
drop a comment all right follow our
Instagram because we do giveaways and
[__] on there it's [__] awesome thank
you guys so much for being here Marty
thank you guys this is a sick day it's
almost six o'clock which is in the same
we got here at 11. damn
all right we've been talking explosive a
minute yeah all right guys thank you so
much for being here this has been
fresh start this has been a new
beginnings this is us this is the dope
as usual podcast
season three
don't be scared really starting right
now all right season three's really
started up right now that's how I like
to say in my head we're going hard now
this is the time
um for everyone out there that didn't
like the move I'm very sorry but we're
back if you didn't like the move it's
okay
maybe something's missing these were the
soundboard something was off we're back
we fixed that [__] we're back with a
solid ass [__] long ass episode and
uh we're coming back fulcrum Goblin Eric
Khan we're trying to set that up for
next episode if not I don't know we'll
see who we get all right go bug blp
kosher go bug that fool I can't wait
till he's right here I'm like yo hit a
hard flip 360 Flip rap
[__] this [__] do everything oh man
they're so sick
um guys thank you so much for being here
uh this has been the dome's usual
podcast this has been like I said season
three if you're out there driving please
be safe pay attention to the road
remember if you're in the state of
California and you get pulled over they
say it smells like weed in here it's not
I'll break in the law anymore all right
prop 64. don't let them search your car
if it's uh smell is not probable cause
like to tell everybody that don't open
[__] hey smells not probable cause if
there's no smoke if you're smoking a
joint where they pull you over as long
as there's no smoke coming out of your
car they cannot open your door I don't
know why I feel like I need to tell your
ass that if you're smoking a joint in
your car all right be safe but if your
car smells like weed remember if you're
California don't open that [__] by law
all right let's [__] needed to say
that
that's cool
[Music]
yeah I just got into that right now I
just felt like and if you're smoking a
joy [__] driving don't [__]
yeah thank you guys so much for being
here if you're driving please be very
very very safe if you're at home thank
you for chilling with us this [__]
long if you're at work if you work for a
[__] four hours you have killed a
shift good job and if not this is your
halfway mark through your shift
all right good [__] if you're at school
don't worry school's not forever and uh
yeah thank you guys thanks for being
here this has been fun go watch the Ted
talk tedx talks on YouTube that
[__] almost 40 million
subscribers on that channel that's crazy
how to make Con how to make content a
career how to make
content creation or career is it God
that's a [__] tongue twister how to
make content creation a career maybe we
should change that title is that really
what it is yeah
she's a tongue twister
at tedx talks oh how to make content
your career oh okay
TED Talk
oh oh no that's that's ours right there
make content creation a career there you
go make content creation a career that
is on tedx talks YouTube channel you can
go watch our BTS version It's called
whatever I just said I'm getting very
confused all right it's on my double
Joel Channel all right to Thomas
I I haven't really eaten I feel very
like
wobbly uh-huh all right here we go we've
been here for a minute thank you guys so
much for being here Marty I'm very very
stoked to be back I can't wait I'm about
to punch a hole in the [__] wall I'm
so excited this is [__] awesome and
then me and Marty are going to rearrange
this entire room how we want this to
feel
all right so we can hang out in here and
smoke bowls and do [__] because this is
our [__] studio all right thank you
guys so much for being here this has
been the dope as usual podcast before
you leave leave a like notification Bell
subscribe all that stuff my name is dope
is y'all Thomas whatever you want to
call me this is Marty O'Neill my co-host
thank you for being here this is dope as
usual podcast we've talked about life
drugs problems accomplishments and
everything in between and we will talk
about everything in between and say [__]
and say whatever we want thank you guys
so much for being here have a dope ass
day oh
good [__] yes
yes bro if I was Sonic right now I'm
[__] rings
that's how I feel right now
oh
[Music]
perfect